uh we have a new policy on prehearing
and on the announcements the sign in
sheet will not take new
entries to allow them to speak after 8
o'l in the morning if you sign up at the
end of the hearing however the chair
will provide an opportunity for you to
speak after all registered names are
called at that time raise your hand to
be recognized the signin sheet will
close for purposes of registering your
opinion and
11:59 the day of the
hearing
and House Bill 544 for example is still
Gathering signatures and Pam will send
us the complete list tomorrow after the
closed so as chair of the house Edna
committee I find that due to the state
of emergency declared by the governor as
a result of the covid-19 pandemic and in
accordance with house rule 67 Governor's
emergency order 12 first to executive
order
20204 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically this is a public
hearing on bills referred to the
committee and scheduled in the house
calender for today an executive session
may be held on any Bill referred to the
committee please note there's no
physical locations for members of the
public to observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in ordance with the emergency
order I am confirming that all members
of the committee and select legislative
staff have the ability to communicate
contemporaneously during this meeting
dur through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
the zoom platform or by telephone all
necessary access information has been
available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general fortb website the notice for
this meeting complies with house rules
and RSA
91a anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS le. state. n.
Us in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote
we'll start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance when each member stayes
their present please also State whether
there's anyone in the room with you
during the meeting which is required
know representative Alro present in the
Bailey
representative Bailey I had difficulty
alone representative
alone uh representative
fno I am present at my home in Rochester
currently alone representative goalie
present at home and my wife is in the
other room representative
gr present at home and my husband is on
Judy representative
Judy yes pres my wife is in the in the
other wom and I am alone right here
representative
Lara I'm here home and the family is at
home also representative leus is here
you're in the committee representative
Maguire is here representative
Brian I am present I'm here in Nash and
alone representative Pearson is uh
expected uh representative Roy
here uh representative s
naso I'm here in ringe and I'm
alone representative
Schmidt I'm here in my home office in do
I am alone representative show it I am
here in my home in Pembrook uh alone
representative Schultz good morning I am
and my residents and conquered and my
husband Jean Taylor will be in and out
of the
room Pres representative
room that is the role all that
representative pear expected all right
excellent glad you're all
here resuming the hearing on House Bill
Yates morning uh thank you for having me
my name is uh Scott Yates I am uh alone
in the I don't know if Witnesses have to
say this too but I am alone in the room
um my family is in other rooms uh I am
um I live at 994 South Washington Street
in Denver Colorado uh and thank you uh
uh to the chair and to the members of
the committee uh and to representative
yo for bringing this bill um I I won't
take long with my testimony I know that
you've heard a lot about it already um
this is something that I do as a as a
hobby I just do it for fun uh I've been
doing it for about seven years now and
uh the reason I do it is that really
nobody else was doing it nobody else was
advocating for the idea that we should
stop changing the clocks twice a year
and and the more I looked into it the
more I realized how deadly the changing
of the clocks is like whether or not you
like one time or another time uh the
actual change of the clocks in the
spring is really deadly um traff traffic
accidents go up heart attacks Strokes
workplace accidents workplace
productivity goes down lots of reasons
uh verified by lots of science over lots
of different um uh uh areas that make it
clear that it's a bad idea to be
changing the clocks um the uh solution
that you have before you uh I advocate
for I understand that there's some
opposition to it because there's always
a question and this happens in every
state I think this is maybe the 11th or
12th state I've testified in um and
there's always questions that come up
about what happens with our neighbors uh
especially for broadcasters uh how do we
end you know we don't want to have more
confusion and that's a legitimate issue
it's why we operate under What's called
the uniform time act of 1966 because the
federal government wanted to make sure
that individual jurisdictions weren't
changing the time every uh you know
every year or so because there were a
couple of dozen states a year between
World War II and 1966 that would change
their time and so now that doesn't
happen anymore under the uniform time
act uh the problem is that they didn't
make it so that a state could freeze
into permanent daylight time the way
that they can in permanent Standard Time
the way that Arizona Hawaii and Puerto
Rico do so this is a solution that uh
addresses that it's a it's a good
Regional solution it's not going to go
unless Massachusetts goes and the
reality is massachusett isn't going to
go unless Connecticut goes and then the
harder nut to crack is that Connecticut
isn't going to go unless New York goes
so New York for the first time this year
has a bill before their legislature uh I
would say that overall and then I'm
happy to take any questions I'll end on
this point
overall the actual language of this bill
doesn't actually matter all that much uh
because it's going to need Federal
authorization we need the feds to get
involved and uh when I started this
there was absolutely no federal interest
uh last year there were three bills that
went and I talked to the offices of all
of the sponsors of all those three bills
and all of them said that the number one
way that they could get co-sponsors for
their bill was to go to the states that
had passed something we have 15 states
now that have passed some kind of
legislation saying that they want to
lock the clock in Mo and all of them
have the intention of locking into
permanent daylight time uh so they would
the sponsors for those Federal bills
would go to the senators or the
representatives from the state that one
of those 15 states that had passed a
bill and there are states all over the
country from Washington to Florida
everywhere in between they would go to
those States and they would the
representatives or senators from those
States and say would you be a coast
sponsor of our bill uh you know that
this is something the people of your
state want as expressed by the state
legislature so uh I would uh uh
recommend uh humbly that don't get too
wrapped up in the particular details of
what's in this bill passing it is a
great way to signal that yes we here in
the Granite State uh are believers that
we should fix that we should lock the
clock and stop the the barbarism of
changing the clock twice a year
uh and with that I'm happy to answer any
questions and thank you again for
allowing me to testify remotely I really
appreciate it thank you very much
represent black us um thank you for
taking my question thank you madam chair
so you said that uh this would require
congressional action my understanding
from previous testimony was that if we
wanted to stay in the Eastern Time Zone
but stay on daylight savings time that
that would be the case but if we wanted
to move to Atlantic time zone that would
not be required you know for a fact
which which way it is uh yeah it's just
it thank you for your question and thank
you madam chair uh the it's slightly
different from that if I understand your
question right and I'm and I'm sorry if
I didn't get it quite right uh it's it's
legal now for a state to move to
permanent Standard time so you could
lock the clock now into the time zone
that you are in now uh that's what
Arizona Hawaii and Puerto Rico did
um if you um uh wanted to move into
Atlantic time that is the theory behind
this bill and it's a novel Theory and I
support it I have asked the Department
of Transportation in Washington very
specifically about this they have a they
have a lawyer that works you know on
this issue she it's not all she does she
does other things but this is a specific
thing that she works on and I said is
this Theory correct if uh New Hampshire
passed a law that said they want to move
into Atlantic time and then say on
Atlantic Standard Time year round would
that be legal under uh the Department of
Transportation rules under the uniform
time act and her response was typical
for a DC uh uh employee which was well I
can't answer a hypothetical uh I'd have
to see the bill when it comes so uh you
know I encourage I I I like the novel
approach and I I encourage any progress
on doing what we can to lock the clock
it's it's unclear there there's no clear
answer to the question of if it would
actually be legal to move into Atlantic
time as one state and go into Standard
Time uh it I I would love to see it
tested I would love to see that
hypothetical proved out but at this
point it's uh not not specifically clear
committee I I have a question Madam
chair yes representative
sh thank you madam chair so Mr Yates uh
the question I have is do you have an
opinion on which time zone is the best
for us to be in I I take your other
arguments at face value uh but the
question
is the East this this Zone that we're in
currently is very long it goes all the
way to uh the western edge of Indiana I
believe um and uh and
and the the actual relationship of the
time uh to the Sun uh where we are um is
the question I have so can you opine on
that or is that not the area of your
expertise uh thank you very much for
your question and thank you madam chair
uh the New Yorker did a story about this
effort a few years back and they used
the word agnostic they said Scott Yates
is agnostic on this question uh and and
that's where I am I I don't have a
particular opinion I I do think that
each state should make an opinion and uh
and when I bring up the fact that you
brought up just now that maybe we should
look at the geography a little bit when
making this decision and not make a
blanket decision for every state in the
country without respect to where they
are in the time zone I think that that
is um not not the most helpful it it
makes it more complicated and sometimes
people shy away from complexity but
you're exactly right I've written on my
blog a couple of times about the fact
that you know Boston is about a thousand
miles away from Indianapolis it's crazy
that they are both in the same time zone
uh uh especially when you look at the
fact that Indiana because of some
peculiarities of Indiana has a couple of
sections of the state that are carved
out that are actually in the central
time zone so one of the things that
could happen if there was Federal
legislation saying that we should lock
the clock is that Indiana could
potentially unify and go onto what is
currently uh Standard time for them they
would then the whole state would be
unified and they would be in the same
time zone as Chicago which is more their
natural area of Interest my view is
that's up to the people of Indiana for
New Hampshire I think that uh it's
perfectly appropriate for you to
actually be in Atlantic time Atlantic
Standard Time in a sense because you are
you know along with a lot of New England
jutted out into the Atlantic and you are
uh geographically positioned east of New
York City which is sort of the center of
not really it's still on the Eastern
edge of the Eastern time zone so it
would make
uh I think
geographically uh for the State of New
Hampshire it would probably make the
most sense to be in uh what is now
permanent what would what would be
called permanent daylight time uh but
but I leave that question up to you I've
got a lot of resources on my blog uh
that can help you sort of look at what
uh what the science is on which time
zone that you would want to be in but um
uh I I think the the and I would say
just one more thing to answer your
question very briefly which is the trend
of the states all all of those 15 states
that have passed something and nearly
all of the states that have uh uh
something proposed for this year uh have
proposed moving into daylight time there
hasn't been a state yet that has taken
any action to move into Standard Time so
uh and that I think is an expression of
the constituents of the lawmakers that
have brought this forward which is they
want to see uh their constituents all
want to see permanent daylight time
thank you again for your
representa
representa has a question thank you m
Madam chair um Mr Yates you have um
there's a long list of states that have
passed something although they're you
know different and you've been working
on this for seven years and I know it's
been going on longer than that so in all
occurred uh thank you for your question
and thank you madam chair uh no I I I
mean this is one of those funny things
about momentum um you know when I first
started this seven years ago there was a
lot of there was talk about it and
people complained about it but uh there
wasn't any state that had actually
passed anything there were there were
maybe 10 states that even had a proposed
Bill uh uh this year we have
uh well we have 15 states that have
passed something so they don't
necessarily have another bill this year
so now we have actually fewer States
considering it than we had last year uh
because 15 states have passed something
but 15 states having passed something uh
three Federal bills with lots of uh uh
uh co-sponsors from both sides of the
aisle like this is one of those things
where uh nothing has actually happen
because the answer is a little bit
complicated but uh the momentum toward
change is clearly there and uh I my
impression I testified I guess two weeks
ago now in Nebraska where I had
testified four years previous and when I
was there four years ago it w the
general feeling was we don't want to be
the first state of the union to pass
something and uh the impression I got
when I was there last time was well we
don't want to be the last state in the
country to pass something so I think the
momentum is clearly there but you're
absolutely right there's uh as of today
there haven't been any changes to time
zones uh since the energy Act of 2006
thank you for your
question there
questions right seeing none thank you
very much Mr Gates thank you thank you
for having me uh Scott
spaling good morning Madam chair for the
record my name is Scott spradling I am a
representative and lobbyist government
Affairs person for the New Hampshire
Association of broadcasters and uh we
are here to testify in opposition to
this specific bill uh I'd like to sort
of just run through a couple of the
basic reasons uh why we appear before
you this morning I think first and
foremost from the broadcasters which is
radio and TV in New Hampshire it's
important for you to know that we
represent more than 96 different
stations throughout our small state many
of those stations are part of a network
that broadcasts and shares content
across state lines so while we're having
a conversation about geography from our
perspective um because the foundation of
r entire industry is based on the clock
and on time this is more than a
geographic conversation for us and
that's why we have concerns if I could
just take one quick step back Madam
chair and and and suggest that you sort
of take a look at the history of this
conversation over a number of years that
it's uh been a a little different almost
every time we've had a conversation
about dumping daylight savings entering
the Atlantic time zone and jumping ahead
jumping ahead without daylight savings
jumping ahead with daylight savings
jumping with a coalition of States uh
the Coalition changes so every few years
or so the conversation itself has
seemingly shifted in its details and
from a broadcaster's perspective where
even the move of one hour could make a
tremendous difference it's concerning to
us um we believe right out of the gate
it's important for you to understand
from our association's perspective we
don't dispute the merits of this
conversation what Scott mentioned before
what the prime sponsor has talked about
in terms of the benefits uh what
representative Schultz who's a
co-sponsor um we we understand that
conversation um what we are simply
saying is that a state-by-state approach
is a very dangerous one for our industry
and we would urge you to try to find a
way to have this conversation at the
federal level and not try to do this
peac meal I had a lengthy conversation
with the prime sponsor with
representative yella who's impassionate
about the idea and it was asking me to
go back to our various State
associations to try to figure out if
there's a Tipping Point like what Scott
just talked about building momentum are
there 10 states in a coalition 15 and
what I found was that um like he almost
explained uh in his testimony whereas
this bill is connected to Maine and
Massachusetts Massachusetts is connected
to Connecticut which is connected to uh
New York you almost start doing the you
know Them Bones song where everything's
connected to everything and that's kind
of our point the broadcasters don't want
to do a coalition they absolutely
believe it needs to be done at a federal
level and there's a very strong economic
reason why so this bill would
essentially create for the continental
US a fifth time zone and in listening to
the testimony I understand the
geographic side of things and I think my
clients absolutely would as well but it
creates some big challenges New
England's a relatively small cluster of
states in both space and population so
if we move it ignores the way that the
broadcast system is set up we broadcast
based on a hub so if you think about
radio and TV programming our our net of
programs that we share with you is a
combination of locally produced programs
and nationally syndicated programs those
syndicated programs are sent out by
clock so as all of you know we have
Prime Time viewing for television right
we've all heard that before the most
expensive advertisements are usually
between 8 and 11: p.m the best evening
shows are during that window and that's
because that is the greatest probability
of the most eyes on that program the
more R you have the more expensive it is
for Revenue because the greater your
overall reach when you make that
adjustment by even one hour it does a
couple of different things it will throw
New Hampshire and the other states into
the Atlantic time zone which would be an
hour ahead so that as we are having this
conversation at uh 10:25 is it would
actually be 11:25 in the morning right
now our prime time would be different
from our New York hub which is in charge
of sending out all of this information
so the 8:00 TV show that you love would
now run at 9 the live sports that you
enjoy watching would now run an hour
later and the struggle for connecting
revenues and eyes for the states that
are in the Eastern I'm sorry in the
Atlantic time zone would uh have a
massive impact on revenues because those
are our main revenue streams um I talked
to a few of our uh various clients to
try to get some kind of an idea of what
this means so for example um local news
would run an hour later Monday Night
Football instead of starting kickoff if
you're a Patriots fan your kickoff is
not at 8:30 it's now at 9:30 which means
the game goes until about 1:00 a.m.
you've all probably collectively
struggled to watch Red Sox starting a
game first pitch at 10:07 on the west
coast when they're playing LA Angels um
that is sort of what the commonplace
time frame would be for um East Coast
games if we make this kind of a shift
for public TV uh the general manager
shared with me that because so much is
syndicated if local viewers with public
television here can find on their cable
channels the other public TV stations
which right now are side by side they
would be able to change the channel and
essentially not be watching New
Hampshire public television which not
only misaligns the key syndicated
programs they do but it knocks viewers
off of the local programming that they
do as as well um uh Peter Frid is the GM
over there he said this would be just
the one hour would be a cataclysmic
shift for their ability to raise funds
which is often viewer supported in radio
to the western side of the state we have
stations that broadcast in both New
Hampshire and Vermont simultaneously and
the question I got from one GM Matt
Housman who runs a number of stations
along the Vermont border he said how do
I schedule my morning show which is live
broadcast locally and then mix in the
syndicated program which would start at
a completely different time than Vermont
that would be a nightmare we would lose
a lot of Revenue we would lose listeners
and I'm not sure how we do it you also
run a file of am broadcast signal rules
I don't know I don't want to get too
deep into the Technologies because quite
frankly I don't know it that well myself
but the bottom line is the federal
government requires AM stations to power
up and power down based on what time it
is and the reason why is because am
radio waves travel farther than FM radio
waves and if you stay powered up at the
wrong time you're going to interfere
with other AM stations that are
broadcasting similarly on the dial and
if you jam if you uh drop down then
listeners who are anticipating heing
your local broadcasting can't hear it
just a one-h hour difference in shifting
between the nighttime and and and um and
morning hours would again make a huge
difference so to do this peace meal is a
uh a frighten ing concept for the
broadcasters and and Madam chair let me
just close with a couple of thoughts um
I I wish representative y um um uh yella
was here I don't know if you recall but
when we were opening the testimony last
week you asked him so what time would it
be right now um if you uh if we were
having this conversation and he
mistakenly said well it would be 9:20
when instead it would be 11:20 I only
rais that this is this is not to
criticize him at all I only rais that
because one of the points that was made
in supporting this is we're going to
eliminate a lot of confusion actually no
we're not uh not only are we not going
to eliminate confusion but if you don't
do this from a federal perspective let's
say the bill passes hypothetically in
Maine and Massachusetts do it too and
we're the three states that Bolt the
other states around us not only will
have different times but they're also
recognizing daylight savings so for four
months out of the year were different 8
months were the same
that's not a a resolution to uh the
confusion of our current situation at
least all of us are in this together on
the Eastern seab board the second point
and and I I respectfully share this
because a lot of what representative
Schultz said in her testimony and
support of her bill makes a lot of sense
to me and I think our broadcasting uh
friends and partners would agree with it
but um she pointed out that uh from her
youth experience and living sort of near
the the timeline it wasn't that big a
deal there weren't that many um uh you
know changes or challenges um but I
would respectfully submit that look at
the history of why we have these time
zones representative Horgan accurately
pointed out that it started because of
the railroads in
1883 that's almost a decade before radio
was even invented forget becoming
commercialized we came well after these
time zones everything came after these
time zones so for us our industrial
analogy to this is you want to rehab the
house but you're going to rip the
foundation out and then try to keep the
house intact for us economically this is
extraordinarily damaging and that's why
we oppose the bill and from from there I
would uh be happy to take any
questions thank you representative Shu
was the
first thank you madam chair good morning
Scott good morning good to see you nice
to see
you um I was listening to your testimony
and
just want to see if I understood
correctly you're basically saying that
because uh the states that jut into the
Atlantic Maine and New Hampshire are a
smaller market for these programs that
would put us at a disadvantage both
economically and trying to negotiate for
perhaps getting programs sent to us in
what we would consider prime time did I
get that right yes yes ma'am um so let
me we'll sort of explore it this way so
um if you watch uh so mu right ABC the
local station so syndicated programming
Ellen degenerous runs at 4:00 um like I
said with the prime time the shows that
run at 8 and 9 and 10 o'clock before the
11 o'clock local mu news kicks in on the
ABC channel those would all have to be
given to us earlier for our Atlantic
time zone to be accommodated meaning
they would have to send a different
syndicated feed to our states and allow
us to run it an hour ahead of the
Eastern Time Zone and my GM from wur
Jeffrey Bartlett has said that's not
going to happen they won't do that for
three states even with Boston being in
that market it's not enough people in
the population to essentially create
this time zone for three states it would
have to be done at a federal level with
a much larger conversation of how this
Network looks like the other practical
aspect to this when I talked about the
uh the the how we're all connected to
this so Connecticut with New York we
connected with the Pennsylvania
Association of broadcasters and they
said they would never leave without New
York and they would uh the Philadelphia
and New York City are so close together
and their broadcast schedules overlap
that's a problem now you're bringing
Pennsylvania into the conversation and
now Washington DC becomes a component of
the conversation because of how the
broadcast markets overlap so it is it's
kind of like dominoes with superglue the
way that the broadcast network ends up
working and so for three um oh I'm going
to use a terrible word three Rebel
states to jump out I love our live free
and die State and and our broadcasters
do too but from an economic and revenue
perspective you'd be chasing eyes to
other Market broadcasts and with the
invention and Advent of of things like
Hulu and other things our viewers could
stay in the Eastern Time Zone even as
we're in Atlantic and that would be a
crushing blow to the revenue streams for
our
broadcasters thank you very much sure
Pearson thank you madam chair Mr uh
spradling um longtime listener first
time caller here
so I'm going to ask you a rhetorical
question they do Broadcasting Canada
right they do yes they do okay Canada
has more time zones than the United
States does already that's right in
Canada they have found a way to handle
this yeah okay so so I I this I don't
see this as something where you guys are
going to have to reinvent the wheel here
when the Canadians are already in
essence doing that now you brought up an
interesting ORD Hulu but you know I was
thinking about a a specific program to
use as an example here and I know you're
not going to like to hear this but I
would be I have no clue what network any
of them are on because I watch them all
in a DVR I don't watch anything live
frankly because I one I don't have the
time and two I'm not gonna sit through
commercials if I don't have to and I
know that you know that's your at your
bread and butter but that's reality okay
I I couldn't even tell you what day some
of my shows are on they just show up on
the DVR and here we go so I think the
way that television works now has
certainly changed Beyond just the aspect
of a time zone and a market because we
have the ability to to I decide what my
time frame is I decide what my timeline
is and I decide when and how I I choose
to watch things and you know I I do it
through a satellite service that has
told me that they have the ability to
track what I
record case in point with our little our
little slip in the Super Bowl years ago
it was the most rewound thing on a DVR
in US history so that we know that they
can track that sort of thing so
certainly your your base of
Revenue off of viewed items can has a
correlation to that because it's
trackable so so I guess my question for
you overall here is you know we already
have a state Arizona that doesn't
necessarily jive with everybody else and
that's you guys are finding a way to
handle that as well why why would the
Hub of New England coming off in the
various states that would be tied to to
the Boston Market really truly be so
devastating when you in fact have two
Canadian time zones that you have to
deal with in correlation so I'm trying
to I'm trying to buy argument here man
but I'm I'm having a hard time okay I
understand um the the Canadian time
zones also predate all of us so I think
the argument about time zones actually
stands from um from our purposes um
geography also matters because New
England is a reasonably relatively small
geography compared to to the broader
expanse of Western States I think the
conversation that we're having here it
we're not we're not so far apart on
reasons why why you would have this
again our clients my clients our
broadcasters don't dispute the merits of
having this conversation and we
recognize exactly what you're talking
about with the geography of this our
entire point is that our broadcast clock
is connected to the entire Eastern Time
Zone and R rgm who is connected to HST
broadcast
which is the ABC Station in Boston so
it's the same family of broadcasting
stations has connected with the folks in
New York City that control the network
broadcast syndicated programs and they
have so much as said that no it would
not be enough for those three states to
go Rogue if you will and for us to be
able to change our broadcast time clock
in a way that wouldn't be damaging so
again this is that mix of syndicated
broadcast and when you get it at what
time and the local broadcasting that
goes on around it and so to make this
move the indication we have and the only
advice that we're really giving is
please talk about this at the federal
level and try to do this in a broader
context because then that way everybody
is at the table at once in fact I I
would certainly encourage the the prime
sponsor and the supporters of this bill
to talk to lawmakers at the legislative
level at the state level in all of these
states and come up with one coherent
approach to doing something like this
because coherence is what we are looking
for that thank you thank you madam chair
programmingsoftware or I'm watching The
Big Bang Theory I'm watching whatever
those are in the can man you know those
aren't this isn't the days of Desi Ares
running over and I Love Lucy and doing a
cigarette commercial and then running
back and continuing the show so I I find
it I don't I just don't see how that
would be difficult to be sending a a
feed to to the New England Affiliates to
show a program that isn't live it's
already something that they're going to
be beaming over to everybody else at a
different time and clearly you're
already handling East Coast West Coast I
I went to college in
Oklahoma there was a transition growing
up in New England and me looking at the
TV going ah Central Time central time
Central Time right because I was not
accustomed to that but I became
accustomed to it so if you could focus
your questions represent par thank you
so I'm just trying to understand that
with the syndication part of it the
beaming of a show why why is that
specifically
difficult to do when you're
already sending syndicated programs
across multiple time zones sure um
because there's also a great deal high
percentage of live broadcasts that
happen and you're ignoring the dozens
upon dozens of of radio stations in New
Hampshire that have to balance a great
deal of local live broadcasting along
with its syndicated programming don't
forget too that you're also knocking out
at least for New Hampshire all of the
local programming that is done live
you're right the syndication windows are
preset and they are not necessarily a
live broadcast although the syndicated
time that New York shares that uh that
broadcast time everybody's picking it up
in that exact hour so uh you know you're
you're a big fan of the movie of the
show blind spot on uh I think it's on
ABC and it runs every uh Thursday from
9: until 10: that's when New York City
will will Syndicate and broadcast the
newest um updated times so you'd be
watching it at 9:00 in Vermont and 10:00
in New Hampshire uh and please don't
overlook the impact on that live local
broadcast so your six o'clock news for
Mu would run at 7 when the six o'clock
news would run at six in the states that
have not moved to the Atlantic time zone
morning radio if you're a fan for
example of um uh Greg in the morning
buzz on WB and wgir that runs from 6
till 10: now it would be from 7 until
11: but you have syndicated programming
that is supposed to start at 10:00 a.m.
or other live broadcast shows that back
that up the talk show networks would be
thrown into some turmoil with this as
well um you've got someone like Jack
Heath who runs from 9 in the morning
until noon on live broadcasts
immediately following live broadcasts
and then noon goes to a syndicated
program on the beny radio stations it is
a uh very big Challenge and there is
potential Revenue lost when you are
throwing us off an hour from the rest of
the
region thank you thank you thanks for
the question uh there's plenty more
representative
Roy thank you can you hear me yes I can
great um my question really simple is we
talked about if we went it would only
happen if Massachusetts went the
Massachusetts will only of Connecticut
goes and Connecticut will go of New York
goes so really if that dominoes to use
your analogy happens would that not
alleviate all of your problems once New
York went so um technically sure if New
York were to join with and we were in
the same broadcast time zone as New York
City was that certainly alleviates the
pragmatic problems at the at the
national broadcast level the local
broadcasting challenges would still
apply especially with radio but um I I
think you're representative Roy you're
on to something and it is exactly why
from our perspective it's why we don't
we simply don't oppose the spill on its
merits it's only to try to figure out
how to do this at the federal level so
that Congress can figure out who what
and how and do it in a way that doesn't
do damage to our sort of broadcast
Nets followup thank you so just a real
quick followup
question isn't that way though that we
get Federal legislators to move is by
doing things like that so if we do this
and ours doesn't really take effect
practically unless New York does now
you've got the actual Geographic not
just the saying we're changing well that
would certainly be an impetus for the
federal legislators to take action kind
of like the Supreme Court doesn't act
unless different courts are have
different different decisions so I just
feel like if if no ever does it it's not
going to
happen so um super fair question
representative and I appreciate it and I
think that the only way that I can I I
can answer it is um we're looking at
this from the terms of potential risk so
if we were to follow that argument
forward and we did do something like
that the risk to us because of this
shift of just one hour is um double
digit risk of revenue losses so I guess
I would I would suggest to you that if
there was an Al alternative way meaning
if there was um not to give
representative yella a a a homework
assignment but if he were able to cycle
this idea to States up and down the
Eastern seab board and do it as a
resolution and an something that doesn't
have the teeth to it that could allow a
potential for this to actually become
law that we're looking at it from the
perspective of risk why ask this
industry to absorb the potential
Financial Risk of this thing happening
in this process when there's another way
to do it that doesn't have the same kind
of a risk and I think that's what we're
looking at here in in our argument if
that makes
veroda I think you're still on
mute I'm sorry thank you that's okay I
think Mr Mr SP spradling and answer my
question it seemed that um we needed
some clarification on how syndicated um
radio and television um worked together
and he answered the question thank you
so much you're welcome right thank you
uh there any other questions
repres thank
you so there's going to be a negative
economic impact in broadcast
Industries U but we've also heard
testimony that there's going to be
economic uh gain in much in a much
broader sector so my question is is uh
given that there's a growing
constituency that uh to use the popular
term has cut the cable period how do we
justify to them the interests of one or
two industries versus the much broader
impacts um that we'll see in in other
areas thank you sure it's a fair
question and for people that are okay
robbing Peter to pay Paul or uh take
making it a nonzero sum game um that's
fine you're picking winners and losers
by doing that approach and that's why
from the association perspective and the
um associations from across the region
and different states the National
Association of broadcasters has taken
the same advice to say let the federal
government do this so I think our
perspective would be there's just a
better way to have this conversation
than doing this peace Meal which brings
forward a Financial Risk to our industry
we don't dispute the those claims about
there being benefits economically that
could be very broad but I think that
you're damaging one to create
opportunity for another when I don't
think you have to do it that way thank
you thank you representative goalie you
had a
question thank you madam chair and thank
you Scott for taking my question good to
see you good to see you uh real quick
question we talk about going from Maine
to New Hampshire to Massachusetts the
leap frog going down to Connecticut into
New York uh my question is as we talk
about those States isn't the Hampshire's
legislation a little different in going
with the Atlantic time zone versus these
other states are going elsewhere in the
time zone yes sir that's part of the
challenge I think Scott Yates who
testified before um gave a good
cross-section you have like I said at
the beginning of my testimony you have
different approaches to this
conversation some like ours are looking
at moving to the Atlantic time zone
other St states have multiple proposals
in front of them to talk about just
eliminating daylight savings which would
keep them in the Eastern Time Zone and
not do the shift and I think from the um
anti-c confusion side of the
conversation I think that's another
reason why it's better to have this from
a macro conversation to avoid the com
the the confusion of uh the potential in
in this particular scenario of having
Maine Massachusetts and New Hampshire an
hour ahead of Connecticut Ro Rhode
Island Vermont and New York unless New
York and Connecticut go with which
leaves Rhode Island and Vermont out but
what about Pennsylvania like it can get
dizzyingly confusing especially when not
all of the states are going to recognize
the fallback spring forward concept of
daylight savings but some will so that
is why we're just suggesting that this
is a conversation best advised at the
top level and have a macro approach to
this um our our perspective is you know
pick your lane and just stay in the lane
but do it from a big Regional
perspective Eastern Seaboard perspective
Federal perspective thank you sir thank
Shu thank you madam chair I I think I
lowered my hand again I decided that um
the opportunity for my question has kind
of gone
P thank you representative sitec I can't
help uh good morning Mr Spradley I can't
help of your idea of using State
initiatives to pressure the federal
government and marijuana comes to mind
but that's not my question this is a
fast irrelevant question does China have
just one time zone I don't know yes they
thought fair enough and and I I do I do
appreciate that representative yella has
that that sort of sense of frustration
and limited faith in the malleability
and quick response of the federal
government to jump in and do something
about this so I completely get that and
respect it um we're just worried about
the economic impact on broadcasters and
how it could be damaging thank you
representative
Schultz hello Mr spradling great to see
you likewise um great points you
probably heard my point uh from last
week and I'm just curious since there
are medium markets that do cover more
would cover probably at a Max two time
zones would that be a way to help
understand the best approach for media
markets that we deal with Excuse me of
Schulz you're co-sponsor you can't ask
questions right I am so sorry that's
quite all right we will move on we have
two other people to
testify Mr
mser
you uh good morning I'm Tom mser from
quinsey Massachusetts uh and before I
read my prepared testimony which I
promise is very brief I just want to
respond to a couple of things that have
been discussed thus far in the hearing
um um one by representative fellows
earlier uh she asked uh Mr Yates um if
any changes had happened since 2014 and
I I don't believe any changes have been
put into effect since 2014 but I want to
remind the her and the committee that
the US Department of Transportation has
made a number of local time zone changes
over the past 20 years uh because it's
in its jurisdiction to do so for example
uh in 2010 Mercer County North Dakota
was relocated from Mountain Time to
Central Time uh in 2007 when Indiana
decided to join daylight saving time uh
a number of counties uh relocated in
across central eastern time to to do
what they preferred so uh it's it's
within the Department's uh purview to
make these changes if they are
petitioned to do so by people who live
there uh and and what we're trying to do
representative yella and I and and
others and Mr Yates uh and you know
people in Connecticut and other states
are saying if we band together we're
bigger than Mercer County North Dakota
and we think we have a good argument to
make uh nationally that this is what we
want to do is a community to move
forward with this time zone um another
point I'd like to make briefly is that
uh Arizona is surrounded by different
time zones and eight months a year it is
essentially on Advanced Standard time
which is basically what Atlantic
Standard time would be for New England
uh where it joins California Oregon and
Washington State so eight months a year
it's with the West Coast four months a
year it's with uh New Mexico and states
in the Mountain Time Zone uh and that's
okay I I don't you know I I I haven't
spoken to the Arizona broadcasters but I
imagine that they are are functioning
okay but but again this is this is not a
simple issue this is why we think we
should uh tread carefully we shouldn't
just as they do it did in the 7s we
shouldn't decide you know on short
notice to go to daylight saving time all
year round you know that would not be a
prudent thing to do we should do it
thoughtfully and I'm going to talk about
the commission we had in Massachusetts a
few years ago where we thought about
this issue in depth and the conclusions
we came to okay so thank you for
indulging that um I'm here to ask for
your support uh for h85 which would
extend New
Hampshire's observance of summertime
from eight months a year to year round
this Regional move is supported by the
conclusion of a special Commission on
the Massachusetts time zone from
November
2017 my involvement in this issue began
in 2014 when I penned a Boston Globe
oped titled why Mass should effect from
its time zone the column became a topr
red article in the globe for several
days after it was published realizing I
might have a workable idea on my hands I
contacted Massachusetts Senator John
Keenan's office and introduced a bill by
request to convene a commission to study
the idea this is usually where the story
ends my understanding is that bills By
Request rarely go
anywhere so you can imagine my surprise
when I learned that the bill was added
to the 2016 Economic Development bill
before I knew it my little Bill that
could was a law I was nominated to serve
on the commission and we met throughout
2017 our report was issued about three
and a half years ago
Mr yes we have already received your
testimony and most of us have read it do
you have any of the highlights that you
wish to share with us we don't need to
have you read your testimony sure I
appreciate that uh the commission
endorsed the idea by vote of nine to1
and said that we should move as a region
to Atlantic Standard
Time thank you that's marvelous are
there any
questions represent scitec yeah uh are
you representing any particular I
haven't seen your testimony in my
blizzard of emails please say your name
so I have it for sure sure my name is
Tom MERS spelled e is and Edward M as
and Michael S is and Sam w i l e r i Ed
my testimony a week ago
reading I remember seeing it okay are
there
questions all right thank you very much
for your testimony excuse me my hand was
up representative fellows and then
representative thank you um I I have two
questions um one of them was one
question is the um a bill was introduced
well first the first question is wasn't
there a
contingency in the report that of that
study committee that had to do with um
children waiting at bus stops in the
dark and the second question is uh there
was a bill Massachusetts Bill two two
and a half years ago and didn't seem to
go anywhere um did
it thank you for the question
representative fellows uh with the
indulgent of the committee I'd like to
read the paragraph of my testimony that
addresses
that uh I want to finally I want to
address school start times it's true
that if we adopt this change in a vacuum
we'd have kids walking to school in the
dark my wife and I have two children in
elementary school I would never suggest
making a change that puts them or other
children In Harm's Way we learned that
Pediatric Sleep Experts including Dr
Judith Owens of Boston Children's
Hospital who served on the commission
recommend that school not start until
8:30 a.m. well after an Atlantic
Standard Time
Sunrise uh your second question
representative fellows we did have a
bill last session introduced two years
ago uh to to make this change along with
three other states your state Maine and
Rhode Island uh that bill did not pass
so it has been reintroduced in the
legislature uh having having worked in
politics previously uh I'm am no
stranger to the legislative process it
is very very slow I introduced I I wrote
the oped seven years ago um and you know
we had a commission meet over the course
of a year um so this is not again this
is not a a short-term fix nor should it
nor should it
be thank you you representative Schmidt
you had a
question thank you madam chair uh so Mr
mwell would you opine with regard to
where you would recommend with relate
with regard to
suntime that we try to get this cons
Consortium the best use of
the which time zone should we wind up
going to if we can put this all together
sure I would recommend we stick with the
time that New Hampshire is already on
eight months the year and that is we
call it now eastern daylight time but in
a permanent sense we would call it
Atlantic Standard Time eight months a
year there would be no change the only
change we'd experience is from early
November to early March where we would
not
change thank you thank you other
questions from the committee
P mute hello hello good morning um thank
you for having me here and it's an honor
to be here my name is JP I'm the founder
of safe Standard Time a nonprofit public
benefit campaign working throughout
North America and I'm here to ask that
you oppose this bill
hb85 or at least refer it to the
Committees on children and
education and certainly recommend that
you amend uh certainly that you
recommend its amendment to permanent
Eastern Standard Time uh the bill seeks
to unclock change which is a good idea
but it goes about it the wrong way by
seeking Atlantic time Atlantic time is
objectively the wrong time zone for New
Hampshire's longitude your East West
location on the earth is in the Eastern
Time Zone Atlantic time coincides with
eastern daylight time it is permanent
DST by another name it's an extension of
DST into the winter and there's a big
reason why we don't observe DST in the
winter and that's because it makes the
sunrise dangerously late currently your
latest Sunrise is
7:24 a.m. this bill would delay that to
8:24 a.m. most school and work days
begin around 8 a so for two months late
November to early February you would be
forcing most people to start school or
work in the dark they wouldn't see
sunlight until their lunch break or even
until the end of the day and that is
danger and it's
depressing artificially delayed Sunrise
reduces sleep it reduces immunity it
increases illness and accidents clocks
are not arbitrary and when we do things
matters if you were to ask most people
would they willingly set their alarm
clocks an hour early every day would
they wake themselves hours before
sunrise in the cold of winter they would
say no but that's what permanent DST or
Atlantic time in New Hampshire would
mean for them this this this measure uh
this concept this policy permanent DST
was hugely unpopular in World War II it
was again hugely unpopular and it was
even lethal when it was tried again in
the 1970s oil crisis countries that try
permanent DST do not adjust instead they
sleep less their health suffers and they
eventually revert it this policy is
opposed by the national PTA the national
Safety Council the American Academy of
sleep medicine and many more
organizations every advocacy group for
health safety and children's well-being
that has spoken on this issue urges
instead for permanent observation of
geographically correct Standard Time
permanent Eastern Standard Time Keeps
your sunrises before 8 am. it saves your
morning sunlight which doctors tell us
is most necessary for our mood our
health our safety our learning and our
productivity morning sunlight helps you
wake naturally it helps you feel good
and active and on time it keeps you
healthy and alert
uh permanent Eastern Standard Time is
also pre-approved by federal law which
would make this the quickest and easiest
way to end the unpopular clock
change so I ask that you please listen
to scientists and doctors and teachers
and parents do not repeat the bad
history stop this bill until it is
amended to permanent Eastern Standard
Time and I thank you very much for your
time and your
service thank you are there any
questions from Mr representative
Pearson yeah I have I have a question
about something you just said you said
the federal government has already
preapproved the dropping of daylight
savings time for the East Coast for
every state the 1966 uniform time act um
requires that you observe uh your your
proper time zone and it asks that you
change your clocks only on the specified
dates or not at all so that's the route
that Arizona and Hawaii and all US
territories have taken is that they just
do not spring forward they do not fall
back they stay on their Standard Time so
for you in New Hampshire that would be
staying on Eastern Standard Time and how
you decide that is is an internal matter
state thank you other
questions all right seeing none is there
anyone else who wishes to testify on
85 okay seeing none thank you all I'm
closing the hearing on House Bill
885 and re opening the hearing on House
Bill
Burch
representative
Burke uh yes and good morning can you as
they say can you hear me yes of course
okay thank you very much and good
morning to everyone uh I appreciate the
opportunity to come in um I get a video
of me there we go there you there we um
my name is Paul Burch I'm I represent
chesher one the Connecticut River towns
of Walpole West Milan Chesterfield in
Hinsdale I was uh asked to uh come today
provide some expertise if I can on on
this issue of uh facial recognition
software uh to make it clear right off
the bat I
support the HB 499 as it is as it was
submitted I do not support the
amendment uh I don't know if the
Amendments been introduced or not I
wasn't here for the last for the first
half of the
hearing okay so I oppos that Amendment
it was if I refer to it I refer to it
generally as the hopper Amendment
because that's how to iary referred to
it last term when it considered that
Amendment at at some length first of all
my
history uh may be relevant uh at the
time I retired I was Vermont senior
public defender in terms of uh longevity
in terms of number of cases handled and
the like so I represented criminals
alleged criminals as well as uh in
Family Court others for 34 years incl
including sexual offenders against
children and the like which will be
relevant today I know how search
warrants work arrest warrants work I've
handled hundreds if not thousands of of
of such documents I've litigated them
and the like um I know how sexual
offenders against children operate how
they meet how they find victims and how
they use the internet and frankly the
internet has been the best thing around
uh from a pedophile's point of
view um and as a result of that we have
um organizations and um task forces that
have uh that are utilized to to fight
pedophilia and similar crimes uh
internet crimes against children task
force in fact we fund and uh there's
National organizations International
organizations such as interpole and the
like okay uh in how does facial
recognition software uh affect all of
this internet recognition software is
not
evidence it is a tool it's not admitted
into evidence in court it's used by
police to develop um leads and to
develop
evidence um it's used for instance
uh to compare an image of a potential
child sexual uh victim to known images
of of known people to to link them up
it's used to compare a picture taken at
a cre crime scene uh to a database of
mug shots to identify potential uh
suspects uh it's used to um compare a
cell phone image of an unconscious
victim uh to get an ID to notify family
or develop
leads so let me start with a a simple
hypothetical average case the a law
enforcement officer legally
has um uh a thousand
images of uh what may be children in
sexually suggested poses you don't know
if it's a child or not because you don't
know who that image is of if it's an
adult it's not a crime if it's a child
it could be a very serious crime so the
law enforcement officer contacts
Interpol or other similar organizations
that have these huge databases and sees
if there's a match and that's what
facial recognition technology uses and
they will go and say Bing we've got a
match and that picture there
of this unidentified person on this
computer matches up with a picture we
have in our file and we could tell you
that's a picture of Grace Jones and
Grace Jones that picture she was 14
years old at the time and the picture is
uh two years
old now the law enforcement officer has
evidence probable cause to say a crime
has been committed goes to the court
gets a warrant and uh and and proceeds
from there that's kind of your standard
operating
procedure what the amendment does here
what the amendment does here is
eliminate
that process of developing the probable
cause because it would force the law
enforcement officer to go to court with
just this unidentified picture which may
or may not be of an underage child and
go to a judge and sayi got a picture
here um and it might be evidence of a
crime and it might not be and I don't
know but I want you to get me a
warrant it's not going to
happen and that's the problem with the
amendment that that we have here so what
would be the
effect well unfortunately pedophiles are
very knowledgeable about the internet
they're very knowledgeable about police
techniques they're very knowledgeable
about warrant they know how to operate
where it's safe and where it's not
safe no other state to my knowledge has
adopted this amendment so what's going
to happen is your pedophiles are going
to operate at a New
Hampshire you may think that's a good
thing you may think it's a bad thing I
suspect all of you think that would be a
bad thing uh pedophiles are mobile they
will go to where where their victims are
uh which is why folks like detective
mlin and Keane spent you know 15 years
sitting in front of a computer
pretending to be an underage sexually
active child and luring people um into
New Hampshire and arresting them when
they've done a bad thing in New
Hampshire the pedophiles will go to
where their victims go and if New
Hampshire is the only place in the
United States the only state in the
United States that lacks the ability to
effectively go after them um then uh
they're going to come here you can also
think of the riots that happened in DC
at the capol in January
6th uh regardless of whether your
political beliefs are uh about people
joining there or going there there's I
think a general belief that a number of
people misbehaved inside the inside
inside the capital identifying those
people and charging them is done through
facial recognition software by and large
everybody was taking pictures of each
other and and there's people that show
up in the background and things like
that um and uh facial recognition tech
software is used to identify leads then
people go to court all right anyway I
was contacted by the prime sponsor last
fall and asked if I could develop a
bill that would limit the use of facial
recognition software while preserving
civil liberties and I said I I would
make that effort and that's what the
underlying Bill HB 499 is it's based on
a proposed bipartisan bill that's in the
Senate there nothing much is moving in
the Senate so it's kind of sitting there
on one side is Senator Chris Coons and
the other co-sponsor on the other side
is Mike Lee and they represent you know
two different sides of the aisle it's
supported by groups such as Americans
for
Prosperity um and uh HP 499 is based on
a couple of principles one New Hampshire
should establish appropriate guard rails
around the use of facial recognition
technology to ensure Granite Staters are
safe without infringing civil liberties
two the persistent and targeted use of
this technology should be subject to
similar procedural guidelines as other
investigative techniques that raise
comparable privacy concerns so this bill
would require law enforcement to obtain
a
warrant to use facial recognition
technology to conduct on ongoing
targeted
surveillance a warrant based on probable
cause would be required to use this
technology if you want to surveil an
individual for more than 72
hours it can only be used under this
bill can only be used for surveillance
of a specific person surveillance of a
group would require a
warrant the facial recognition
technology in this bill is
barred for use without a warrant after
the individual has been
identified and there's an escape hatch
saying if there's an emergency or
exigent circumstances it would allow
surveillance without a
warrant so what this bill does in short
is
balance civil liberties by limiting its
scope limiting its duration
limiting who can be
surveilled and still allows the police
work necessary to develop the probable
cause to go to court to get the
warrant so it shouldn't harm decent
police work and it balances that with
civil liberties so I urge this committee
to adopt the original Bill HB
499 and to reject the uh the amendment
thank
you thank you
comme repr fellow um yes uh
representative Bert I'm just wondering
if you think there's any Middle Ground
amendment the original bill is is really
designed to be the middle ground between
what
is and and barring facial recognition
technology so the original bill is the
compromise between the two the pro what
we're talking about here and why there
really isn't a middle ground is we're
talking about at what point do you get
the
warrant and the the amendment says you
get the warrant you have to get the
warrant basically at the very very very
beginning and warrants just aren't going
to be granted
then the HB 499 is drafted allows the
development of probable cause but puts
the restrictions on the technology after
the warrant is gotten so that's kind of
the core difference and I don't see how
there thank you other other
questions
thank you very much for represent thank
call good morning Madam chair this is
jeie hesa I'm going to testify on behalf
of the ACLU on this bill if that's
got that's that's on the later bill I'm
sorry for the confusion but good morning
my name is Jeanie hesa I'm the political
director for the American civil
liberties Union of New Hampshire and I I
really appreciate this commit uh work on
facial recognition technology I want to
start by saying the ACLU actually
supports a ban on this technology we are
deeply concerned about how invasive this
technology is in terms of privacy rights
um and are concerned about the fact that
this technology is inaccurate it it is
particularly inaccurate and identifying
people of color young people and older
people it's essentially a good
technology if you're trying to identify
middle-aged white guys but this is not a
reliable Tech otherwise and so we we
actually start from the premise that we
should ban it completely um which is
actually what this committee did last
session um when it passed a bill that
would have banned the State's use of
this Tech um so we oppose the current
version of this bill that is being
presented this session because hb99 as
it's written is pro- facial recognition
it allows unregulated use of this
invasive inacurate technology for up to
72 hours so in responding to one of the
questions previously asked we actually
think the amendment that representative
Smith proposed last week is is the
compromise because it it allowing facial
recognition technology to be used with
just a warrant is certainly a compromise
from from where we stand in terms of our
ideal of prohibiting the tech um but we
accept that that compromise may be just
that it's a way to split the baby and at
least require police to get a warrant
before using this technology I want to
note that facial recognition when it
when it's inaccurate it's not that it
fails to identify you it's that it
identifies you as the wrong person so
there have been multiple instances
across the country of people being
wrongly identified by facial recognition
technology and being arrested for
something they didn't do um the police
show up on somebody's doorstep and says
you know facial recognition identified
you as the person who did this crime
when lo and behold it's the wrong person
and yet somebody's being arrested
they're being taken in in um simply
because this technology wrongly
identified them that's a concern that
really needs to be safeguarded against
and at a minimum at least a warrant is
some measure of a
safeguard um and again I want to note
that other jurisdictions in response to
the representative burch's concerns um
about whether criminals would come to
New Hampshire other jurisdictions are
Banning this technology there've been a
number of cities across the country that
have banned this technology um even
Amazon has actually imposed a one-year
moratorium on the use by law enforcement
of its facial recognition technology so
again the amendment is a compromise the
amendment is a middle ground between
complete unregulated use of this
technology um and creating some measure
of a safeguard um so I'm happy to answer
questions um I have submitted lengthy
written testimony and I I don't want to
bore you with it all um but we strongly
support the amendment and really
encourage this committee to take the
opportunity to build a safeguard um I'll
just Note One Last point we are
concerned about facial recognition
becoming in abundant use and only then
having the legislature try and regulate
it um I would note GPS tracking
technology which is in widespread use
right now right by law enforcement by
security companies and there are a
number of bills every single session
that try and and create guard rails
after the fact regarding GPS tracking
technology and it's simply too hard to
put the genie back in the bottle once a
technology is in ubiquitous use so this
is an opportunity for this committee to
be proactive and to build safeguards
around a technology before it's in
ubiquitous use so your timing is
exceptional right now um and with that
I'm happy to answer questions thank you
representative Roy thank you mad chair
thank you um my question is you
mentioned several jurisdictions across
the country that have b this
technology share
those uh sure I'm just pulling it up on
my uh testimony so facial surveillance
technology has been banned in San
Francisco Oakland Portland Maine and
several towns in Massachusetts including
cluding Boston the Massachusetts
legislature actually passed legislation
last year that would have banned it um
banned this technology by the state um
so this part of it is there's been real
momentum uh to ban this technology since
last summer um because of how inaccurate
facial recognition is specifically in
identifying people of color um and so
there's a racial Justice uh lens to this
um which again you know uh white men are
the ones that tend to be accurately
identified um and it's it's people of
color who tend to be wrongly identified
and therefore wrongly arrested um so a
lot of these jurisdictions are Banning
this technology in response to that um
and on that this is one of the reasons I
would just note why we supported the
prohibition last session is if you ban
the technology now you know you allow
tech companies to come back to the
legislature in two or three years and
say hey guess what we've improved it
we've addressed all the inaccuracies we
we fix we fixed the algorithm it's now a
great reliable technology and the
legislature can then allow its use when
it's a more reliable Tech but we should
start from from the the position of
safety and that is at least restricting
the use of this technology right
now thank are there other questions from
the committee representative
algro thank you for making my question
uh m r i I have a question that I've
seen they're trying to be made a
distinction between
um Information Technology surveillance
versus regular let let me try to
abbreviate this as much as
possible often search and seizure or
violations of search and seizure um are
cases of entering offices or uh forcing
someone to reveal the information in
their wallet their identification and so
forth uh this
is we wouldn't allow that to develop um
probable cause you can't break into
somebody's office and search their files
without a um without a warrant so what
distinguishes this from that is this not
simply and purely never mind the
technology is this not simply and purely
just a uh allowing uh violation of the
fourth amendment to develop uh a
probable cause which we do not do under
any other circumstances in
theory I I want to make sure I'm answer
I'm understanding the question are you
saying in the absence of this
legislation would facial recognition
constitute a violation of the fourth
amendment I guess the shorter way to ask
the question is should there be middle
ground that would allow uh law
enforcement to enter someone's home and
search their
files
uh and if not why should there be middle
ground for someone to use uh facial
technology to facial recognition
technology to develop problem cause
without a I mean I I think I'm
understanding where you're going which
is I think where you're coming from is
where we're coming from which is this
technology um is dangerous from the
moment you start using it right if you
allow 72 hours of use all of the dangers
of facial recognition technology will be
experienced in those first 72 hours like
the the dangers of this Tech don't
suddenly multiply at the 72h hour Mark
um this technology is invasive in that
if it is used to identify you right
somebody can run your face through a
facial recognition software and produce
some me some identity whether it's
accurate or not as a question but come
up with some name very very quickly
within minutes potentially that that is
still a violation of privacy that they
have done that and so there should be a
warrant at the onset like before they
use the technology there shouldn't be
this like 72h hour window where you can
do all sorts of surveillance and only at
72 hours do we start to regulate
it thank you that did answer my question
even though it wasn't put quite so
clearly any
question seeing none thank you oh excuse
me representative Schmidt has a
question thank you madam chair uh good
morning Jean uh so you heard
representative bur's testimony I presume
and he says you ain't going to get a
warrant um under the
circumstances uh that the bill
foresees uh what is your response to
that
yeah I'm afraid I'm going to have to
respectfully disagree with
representative Burch on that I think if
you went to a court with a photograph in
the instance that he
described um where you're where you're
simply trying to ID somebody in the
photo um I think the court would give a
warrant in that instance but again it's
a case by casee situation I think the
struggle with that example is you know
police don't stumble a across a photo on
the sidewalk and go take it to a j judge
there would be some reason that the
police would believe that that photo is
relevant um so I certainly think that if
in that kind of flushed out hypothetical
I think a search warrant could be
obtained follow up followup thank you
madam chair thank you for your answer
Jean so what is your response to the uh
to the obviously very
significant uh child uh sexual predator
uh issue that we confront in this
country and of course we have it here in
in New Hampshire as well so you could
testimony I'm not I mean I I don't want
to get into how do we address that issue
broadly in terms of facial recognition I
guess I would say two things um we've
been
fighting that issue long before facial
recognition technology came along right
there's always these references to the
toolbx to the broad number of tools that
police have and they still have access
to that broad number of tools so I don't
think this issue makes or breaks law
enforcement's ability to address child
abuse and child
pornography um or child trafficking so I
don't think this is going to be the make
or break issue and also I don't think
requiring a warrant is a hurdle warrants
are very standard law enforcement tools
and they are used exactly in this
scenario where you are
balancing law enforcements duties and
responsibilities with the civil rights
of the public and I think a warrant it
is used in so many situations that it's
just natural to extend that to this
technology thank you thank you other
questions seeing none oh wait a second
representative fellow
um yes I just thank you I just wanted to
ask um are there any controls on the FBI
or federal agents using um facial
recognition and if not are there any
proposals out there to do so
representative follows this is New
Hampshire we have no control over what
the FBI does or what they do they accept
in federal courts what we have to deal
courts yeah we can't the FBI is not
under our jurisdiction I'm sorry to
say that is right the only thing I would
add to that representative is that there
are National conversations right now
about um the federal government's use of
this technology because again the same
concerns about the state using it apply
to the federal government using it um so
the conversation that we're having right
now is happening in other states and and
is happening in
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you uh there's someone else
Eber
you should be able to speak now Mr eirt
yourself good morning are you able to
hear me now yes thank you I apologize
very much for the the delay there uh a
little bit of a technical difficulty my
name is Joe Ebert I am a captain with
the state police I oversee the
Investigative Services Bureau and I
appreciate very much the opportunity to
address the committee today I think that
there's been a a great deal of
discussion about uh uh the usefulness of
facial recognition technology and the uh
the guard rails that I understandably
the there are some that want to put in
place I uh am in certainly in agreement
with represent of birch that I'm
concerned that the uh that the amendment
as proposed would uh put law enforcement
in a position where it would be
difficult if not impossible to obtain a
a warrant um because I I I'm I'm not
certain that we would be able to develop
probable cause by the at the point at
which it's uh being required I I would
say to you that I'm I'm very much uh
understanding of the fact that nobody uh
nobody that I work with and certainly
not the division of State Police wants
to um wrongly accuse somebody or wrongly
Target somebody that is uh uh it should
go without saying but we are ardly
against that uh but this is uh we have
found that facial recognition is uh a
part a piece to an investigation
investigations that we've done here in
the state of New Hampshire um by
utilizing outside agencies uh when we
have joint
investigations and you know I think that
it's very important to highlight that uh
facial recognition in and of itself uh
should not be the only determining
Factor as to who an individual is um but
to uh prohibit it as a tool to uh
working toward discovering who an
individual is really puts I you know for
lack of a better term handcuffs on on
law enforcement so I I would just uh
encourage you to uh to give
consideration give great consideration
to the fact that uh this is a you know
as has been said before this is a tool
that we utilize uh you know and we have
found uh that even in cases here in the
state of New Hampshire uh one that comes
to mind specifically was a a a DMV case
an investigation that took place where
we utilized uh this uh technology in our
in accordance with our partners in other
states uh and what we found was that
there were individuals who are
fraudulently obtaining driver licenses
here in the state of New Hampshire and
again uh you know this was done uh
because it was a joint uh Endeavor but
it was it what it showed us is we were
fallible uh in our DMV system for
individuals coming in um and obtaining
one or two or three licenses uh because
we were not utilizing this technology so
again I just wanted to put forward as a
a thought that we really and truly
believe that uh that this is just one
tool um of many and and I I really would
look forward to to the opportunity to
continue to work on this bill I think
there's certainly middle ground that can
be found so with that I thank you so
much for the uh the time to address you
this morning and I'm absolutely willing
to listen to any uh questions thank you
representative Roy has a
see um you speak to if you're able to um
what the representative from the ACL
repr so representative Roy thank you so
much for the uh uh the question I uh I
really cannot speak to uh the details of
of that statement however I'm I'm I'm
more than willing to uh research that
and provide the committee with uh with
what I find what I would uh put forward
to you and what I would put forward to
the committee is
that eyewitness identification is also
fall um and in and of itself should not
be taken um as one piece of evidence
that stand alone so I guess part of me
says that I'm not surprised that there
is some fallibility to uh digital
identification as well which is why
digital ident identification uh in and
of itself should not be used singularly
so I my response to your question is a
uh I don't know that research but I'm
happy to look into it and B uh I think
it's it's typical of anything we find
one piece of evidence in and of itself
is very rarely uh a standalone
prosecutable case is built on that it it
has to be built on a number of different
things um so the fact that there may be
an inaccuracy there I certainly hope
that the rest of the investigation would
flesh out uh what that inaccuracy
was follow up thank you
just would um
you would you would never apply for a
warrant an arrest warrant simply based
on a hit faal recognition without doing
some further
investigation no no so um and that's a
great point and I think that that was
actually uh brought up uh by a prior uh
witness which is it's it is a part of an
investigation but as a standalone piece
of evidence I would never uh go to a
judge and simply say I have this hit
that came from this system that we know
is not 100% but is very good but we know
it's not 100% I would never stand before
a judge and say and therefore I need a
warrant Lee not an arrest War yeah
representative
muted my apologies thank you Madame
chair
Mr Heber um could you please tell us
your how this am this bill and with or
without the amendment would change the
way um the state police or the law
enforcement is operating in the United
States now and if you can't answer the
question could you please get us the
information so what my question is how
would things change with the bill and
how would it change with the bill and
the amendment can you compare those two
to what you're doing now I can try ma'am
and I I will uh and I absolutely commit
to uh getting you further information on
an analysis of that um I think the
original bill as it stood when I
reviewed that bill my uh my concern with
that bill was in the subsection I think
was evidence admissible where it talked
about uh utilization of an outside uh
entity's uh facial recognition system
would have to be in compliance with the
New Hampshire standards I think that
that bill as as I look at that would
certainly change the way that um we are
operating now because it's very hard for
uh us to impose on say the federal
government or another state our um our
rules and our regulations uh as it deals
with the amendment the amendment is
asking for a search warrant to be in
place which is not currently uh what is
required now so I think the the
amendment's a little bit easier um and
again my interpretation of the original
bill um I I very openly tell you may or
may not be accurate but that was my
takeaway under that Evans admissible
portion um that that was what would
change our operating structure as it
stands now I hope that's answered the
question yes followup please
followup and um but the amendment
doesn't do anything doesn't really
change anything about the admissible
evidence correct uh well I think it does
I I and again ma'am I I I I ask you to I
I don't have the I have the screen up of
the uh the hearing and not the uh the
bill itself but I would ask you to uh to
look under that uh admissibility where
there was a statement in the original
bill which I think said something to the
effect of uh utilization of evidence
derived from A system that was not
compliant with the state of New
Hampshire's uh would be would not be
admissible as opposed to the statement
that's in the current Amendment um which
actually uh the in the the language in
the current amendment is a little bit
more agreeable which says the
utilization of the the state's own
utilization of facial recognition so I I
think that's the difference yes and I'm
sorry I do see that in the bill now and
the amendment I didn't earlier thank you
okay representative Schmidt had a
question thank you madam chair um
Captain thank you very much for being
here today uh one of the concerns that
was raised especially by uh
representative burch's testimony was the
the issue of uh child sex sexual
predators uh and that uh that if we were
to uh pass the bill as amended the with
the proposed amendment that is to say uh
that this would uh you know handicap
police and actually act as a magnet for
uh for SE child sexual Prejudice who are
using online resources uh who are mobile
and and who are willing to move uh and
it would it would put New Hampshire
especially you know in the crosshairs of
such criminals so can you comment on
that aspect I can in a a general sense
represent Schmid um and and here's what
I can tell you from my um my experience
the representative bur I listened to his
testimony very closely when he talked
about the the sexual predators and their
um their ability to keenly be aware of
the laws in each state so uh the extent
to which this would uh open a a portal
or or create a loophole or make more
difficult the uh the investigation into
sexual predators um you know I can see
certainly where he's coming from on that
and I I have some level of agreement
with that as well whether or not that
would attract people to the state of New
Hampshire that's a much more difficult
question for me to to truly give an
answer to but anecdotally I will tell
you that it's been my experience that
individuals especially those uh who are
sexual offenders gravitate toward the
states uh that have the lightest sexual
offender uh requirements so I I I do
think do I do I think it would be a mass
uh movement all at once upon passage of
the bill no but I do think unfortunately
this information is shared in the forums
in which they visit um and could very
well lead to uh more Predators uh
visiting the state of New Hampshire
based upon a notion that they believe
that it is safer to operate within the
uh the boundaries of the
state thank you very much I'm I'm
reminded of the case of Jeffrey Curley
uh thank you are there other
questions from the committee seeing none
I see that Professor Sher wishes to
speak
again
Professor
Sher
hello hello yes there you are I'm sorry
I technical difficulties uh let me
preface what I'm about to say with this
uh I have the utmost of respect for
representative bur uh he and I have
worked together on any number of bills
uh and I uh I have great respect for his
judgment uh that said he's just wrong
here if the police as to the sexual
offender uh uh issue uh and the the
sexual predators issue if the police
have a photograph or an online video of
an individual engaging in sexual conduct
with somebody who may be
underage
every judge I ever practiced in in New
Hampshire uh and all the judges I've
talked to and trained and all the
students I've had who are now judges if
they had a police officer come to them
and say we have a picture of this sexual
conduct occurring the the person in
there may well be underage appears to be
underage I'm not certain about that I
want a search warrant to use facial
recognition
technology uh at interpole or wherever
every judge I have ever trained or ever
taught or ever appeared in front of will
issue that search warrant you do not
need to be certain that the individual
is underage the victim is underage in
order to get a search warrant a search
warrant is based on probable cause it's
not based on
certainty um number two um
uh representative bur said you know the
original 499 requires uh uh the court
issue a warrant once after 72 hours it
doesn't say that the word warrant is
never issued in the original never used
in the original 499 it talks about a
court order it doesn't say whether
there's probable cause needed for the
court order Reasonable Suspicion needed
for the court order none of that is
mentioned uh uh finally I refer uh the
committee to uh my written statement as
to the reliability issue uh and refer uh
very briefly back to axon corporation
which is the leading provider of of uh
devices to uh law enforcement including
body camps it's the leading purveyor
body camps they have chosen under advice
of a independent Ethics Committee not to
use facial recognition technology BEC
with their body cams because they don't
feel certain about it so um I uh more
than willing to entertain questions and
thank you thank you uh Madam chair for
letting me to speak again representative
Roy has a question thank you madam chair
thank you Professor take my question um
we hear this term prob cause used as as
over to lay though would it not be
accurate description problem just say
that means more likely than
not
uh uh no and yes yes to a a Layman as
any Professor good professor would I'm
going to give you two answers yes to a
Layman it sounds like more likely than
not but uh the body of case law out
there interpreting what probable cause
is is closer to something like I have
reason to believe a crime may be
committed and if I get this search
warrant uh I will have an opportunity to
figure out whether that's the case or
not so it actually is not viewed under
the law as more likely than not it's
just I have reason to believe that there
may be based on these hard facts that
I've articul ated out loud I have reason
to believe based on these hard facts
there might be a crime committed so in
in representative burch's example there
is a picture sexual conduct is or a
video sexual conduct is occurring the K
the victim of sure looks like they may
be underage or may well be underage and
it I've gotten this from a website that
traffics in that kind of that kind of
victim um give me a search warrant so
that I have reason to believe they're
underage I can get a search warn in that
case because there's all the elements of
the crime other than some uncertainty as
as to the age of the victim and and I'll
I'll leave it at
that thank you representative Schmid you
have a brief
question I have a question Madame chair
um thank you uh so Professor Sher uh the
element of speed uh is has been
referenced here uh and I'm wondering
whether uh there's any additional delay
uh with the amendment procedure uh Visa
uh without uh given the given the the
benefits of Technology uh modern
technology in the certainly in the 21st
century it is not difficult to get a
warrant very quickly certainly in the
Circ circumstance that uh that
representative Burch indicated it's it's
pretty easy to get a search warrant so
the delay particularly since we're not
talking about an incident that is
occurring as we speak the delay would be
you know minimal less than an hour uh in
most circumstances in my experience in
New Hampshire thank you are there other
questions for Professor
shower great thank you thank you thank
you very much um for taking my testimony
and um I I want to um address I think
that we're only talking right now and
correct me if I'm wrong Madam chair
about the amendment
we're talking about the base bill but
the amendment is also being discussed
because it was presented at the hearing
uh the first part of the hearing okay
thank you that that that helps
um I understand that there are a number
of people who have some very very strong
feelings about the use of facial
recognition technology and that there
are a myriad of instances in which this
could be perceived as being wildly
inappropriate and I would just like to
draw your attention to um back to some
of the testimony that representative
Burch gave and can ask the committee to
please
consider um if there is a will to go
forward with any kind of legislation
like this that you consider putting in a
carv
out for the use of
identifying um children and seniors
years this legislation as written and as
amended will actually impede the
identification of missing persons who
are subject to both Amber Alerts and
silver alerts um and we have had a
number of those here in New Hampshire
and I would submit to you that while
Professor Sher seems incredibly
confident to the point of cavalier in
his ability to secure search warrants
time is of the essence when searching
for a missing child when searching for a
missing senior representative Al Schuler
please do not insult the other
continue my apologies madam chair I will
um so I will I will say that in my
opinion uh Professor Sher is wrong and
um the acquisition of a search warrant
to use um cameras while searching for a
missing child through an Amber Alert
missing senior through a silver alert
and a child um who is in transit with um
with somebody who is subject to um an
alert through the national Center for
missing and exploiting CH exploited
children we know that in those three
instances time is of the essence and
respectfully I ask you to make sure that
there is a carve out if the committee
insists on going forward with this for
um for those instances um our internet
crimes against children task force needs
that our um Child Abuse Prevention
Advocates request that and our children
who go missing in New Hampshire need
that um and I thank you for your time
thank you very much are there questions
aler uh representative sitech carve out
sense uh thank you thank you very much
representative scitec um when this bill
first came around uh when this bill came
around in the last session it um was
amended to include a carve out or an
exception for the use um in the cases of
child U missing children um and child
exploitation I'm respectfully requesting
that we also add in silver alerts um
because you know that is of a con that
is of a new concern um and that be added
into um the legislation should this
legislation go
forward be assured my intention is that
I don't think this legislation should go
forward at all um but if it does
respectfully put in a an exception for
the use in those
instances thank you representative algro
and then repres of SM quick question for
Amber Alerts and silver alerts should we
build in a carve out uh allowing police
to kick in the door of an office without
a warrant to gain information in a
hurry I I don't understand the
connection I'm sorry question repres
please don't argue with the witness no
I'm I'm actually asking let me I'll try
to rephrase it thank you uh we have the
same situation if a child was missing or
or a u an elder is missing uh and the
police believe the law enforcement
believes that there's information in
someone's office uh that they need in a
hurry and so my question is should we
um should we allow violations of the
fourth uh Amendment under those
circumstances as well I hope I ask that
in a a better
format um well I
specifically and I'm sorry who am I
speaking to I'm sorry this is
representative alra thank you
representative algro I'm sorry I cannot
see who's who on the the screen that's
of people who are in the
lob um uh it's it's my understanding
that
specifically House Bill 499 and House
Bill 499 um as amended um the the
instance of kicking indoors or
move moving into physical spaces is
actually not addressed and this bill
specifically addresses the use of facial
recognition technology to identify
people um and my request is that when
we're looking to identify children um
who are being are exploited children who
are missing seniors who are missing that
if we can make that an easier task to do
so that we can protect the public safety
for those people that we allow for that
to that technology to be used and not
have New Hampshire become um kind of a
technological dead zone for being able
to use that technology I certainly would
be um distressed to have a child cross
through the tolls at Route 95 who is who
has been um kidnapped and is being
exploited and is the subject of an amber
alert um and be able to be transported
all around the state and we can't we
can't identify them because you know
we're working with a
72-hour probable Co cause search warrant
um when we might be able to see them at
A T at a toll um we might be able to see
them at a gas station um so when we're
looking for senior citizens who
have you know who are in danger and are
the subject of silver alerts I'd like to
see all tools be able to be used to get
them home safe thank you thank you rep
Schmidt do you have a brief question I
do thank you madam chair uh so
representative aler uh do you have
proposed language or an amendment to uh
effectuate the carat you've
referenced um I would be happy to
provide that to you representative
Schmidt I only became aware of the amend
m m um a short while ago so um I did not
realize I am coming to you on the quick
but I would be happy to provide that
carve out if that is something that you
would be interested in
proposing thank you very much you're
welcome is there anyone else who wish
other questions from represent all
Scher seeing none thank you very much is
there
Connelly
yourself hello Madam chair can you hear
me yes thank you apologies took a little
bit to transfer into the Matrix there uh
so uh for the record my name is Ross
Connelly I'm I'm the deputy state
director for Americans for Prosperity
New Hampshire and I'm here to voice our
support for HB
499 uh I'll be pretty brief here we
believe that uh fed facial recognition
technology as has been pointed out can
be a powerful tool to identify suspects
find missing persons and solve crimes
but in a number of cases the technology
has been used improperly by law
enforcement and other
jurisdictions like being used as a sole
rationale for an arrest or without
meaningful human review uh this
technology also raises the possibility
of creating a panopticon of continuous
surveillance of individuals or groups in
public spaces and HB 499 strikes the
right regulatory balance by allowing
state law enforcement to access this
emerging technology but it requires them
to receive a court order before they
engage in ongoing surveillance which has
been pointed out is a Time greater than
72 hours uh this the legislation also
allows law enforcement to use this
technology if there are emerging
emergency
circumstances uh which is a natural
extension of existing evidentiary common
law uh which I believe would address
some of the concerns from uh
representative Al Schiller uh an HB 499
would be an important first step in and
I'll point out first step in creating a
a proper guard rails of overuse of this
technology uh there is more to be done
obviously on this issue uh with with any
new techn technology state and local law
enforcement should create and publish
guidelines for how they should use this
technology and circumstances not
considered by this legislation to ensure
it's non-discriminatory
and absolutely not the sole basis uh for
arrest so for those reasons we urge the
committee to move HB 499 out to pass and
I I'd be happy to take any questions if
there are any thank you representative
leus uh um so are you speaking on the
bill as originally introduced on the
amendment or if on the bill what's your
view on the
amendment uh so I I I thank you for the
question representative uh I I have not
seen the full text of the amendment um
from what I can tell uh we we wouldn't
be opposed to the amendment certainly um
and uh but we do support the bill as it
as it's written as well so uh you know
what we're looking for is creating those
those guidelines and some restrictions
on overuse of this technology uh and we
think the the bill as written takes a
great first step uh the amendment would
would create uh some some e even more
stringent uh guard rails for it and and
we certainly support that as well um but
uh you know either way it's it's a good
first step towards uh reigning in this
technology thank you are there other
committee seeing none is there anyone
else who wishes to testify thank you
time seeing none in that case I will
close the public hearing on House Bill
499 the committee should know that there
was an opening for next Friday and so I
have scheduled an exact session for
house bill Bill
499 and House Bill
211 and also any other bills we may get
to which is going to include most of the
ones we we I thought we would have time
for today so on that's on Friday the
o'clock that will give us time to talk
about and think about these
bills um
the hearing for 5:44 resumes at
1:30 so I would like to with your
permission exec aail or to before we go
lunch representative scitec you're
stepping out for a moment that's
fine M chair I'd like to um make a
motion to um up I to pass on the
amendment to House Bill
that I'm sorry madam chair what was the
motion I just missed it I'm sorry ought
you wish to speak to your motion
representative groda yes I will thank
you very much um the U main bill um
basically um ratifies the um amendments
to the building codes that have occurred
since the last
um for a while and the
amendment
um essentially just includes the some of
the ones that weren't in the original
bill that have happened since
then I sort of said that a little
backwards I hope people
understand and who is clerking in
absence representative laus will will
will take any note of any motions and do
any roll calls if
necessary we get that
far sorry uh the motion I'd like to
speak to my second and say that the
amendment was a request of the Fire
Marshall and it includes things like
amending the fire code
to enforce the new that um sprinklers
are not required in one or two one or
two family houses that the historic
houses
um code should be used rather than the
basic um new house code for a lot of the
fire code issues and and in other ways
makes the fire code more appropriate for
New Hampshire it was passed by the board
of Fire
Control in 19 sometime it was rep passed
in December of 2020 because
it the fire code amendments expire if
not authorized by the legislature so we
are I
added um I added these after the bill
was drafted and
amendment seeing none in that case
representative scite is back the motion
is ought to pass on Amendment 030 four
to House Bill 72 made by representative
the
okay let me make sure we
are voting on the adoption of amendment
0304 H for House Bill 72 the motion was
moved the moved by representative Gro
seconded by representative
Maguire that correct that's correct all
right uh representative Roy yes clerk
votes yes representative Pearson yes
representative
yakovich yes
representative leus yes representative
Allegro yes representative
Bailey
yes represent representative
lenara yes representative Santo
naso yes representative goalie yes
representative
Judy
Judy are you
there yes okay thank
you representative
Schmidt yes representative
Schultz yes representative
fellows yes representative funno yes
representative groda yes representative
nothing person BR do you have a further
motion yes I do Madame chair I'd like to
move a to pass with Amendment on House
Bill
again do you wish to speak to your
motion yes I will thank you um this
House Bill 72 um includes the
ratification of amendments that have
been made by state building codes and
State Fire codes this is a bill that
passed last year and um did not make it
through the house I mean made it through
the house but didn't make it back um
based on an Omnibus Bill so and I think
that this bill will bring New Hampshire
up to um current code in
law thank you
anyone represent lus yeah either for
representative grer or for you just give
me some idea the nature of the changes
this uh I mentioned the
speaking actually get the vaccine that's
I don't know who's
either yes if you're not speaking keep
yourself muted the building code changes
include things like alternate methods of
uh building structures and and
reinforcing floors for fireproofing or
actually access to
firemen uh they limit some of the
extremes of the energy code to address
the fact that we have a lot of houses
that don't have mechanical
ventilation uh those are the ones I
remember but there are other
uh yeah but most of them are
simplifications or cost savings for
building okay and they've been
exhaustively fought over by the building
code review board which includes the
Architects the office of and planning
etc I agree with that it also involves
thermal
values and
um having to do with the construction of
homes that are built in this this
certain climate zone and um relative to
um our
values the yes the other thing is that
these are changes to the
2015 building code which is what the
state is at we have not yet adopted the
2018 building code which is
the C version more or less but we will
probably consider doing so next year
when it's uh when the bugs have shaken
out if I might add I think this
committee discussed that and the
agreement was that we would adopt the
codes two to three years after the been
in
effect yes there's always some
U errors and omissions in the code that
speak that case U the motion is ought to
pass with Amendment on House Bill 72 and
the clerk can call the RO representative
Roy yes cler votes yes representative
bovich you were here a minute ago yes
thank you representative leus yes
representative Allegro
yes representative
Bailey
yes
chair I'm hearing a great deal of barble
and can't hear the
response thank you for
represent representative lonaro you have
a vote representative
lonaro
yes representative Santo
representative goalie yes representative
Shu yes representative Judy we
representative Schmidt yes
representative
Schultz yes representative
fellows yes representative fno
yes representative
groa
O'Brien yes and the chair yes 190 again
19 does anyone object to
consent okay in that case we put it on
consent representative Shu do you have a
uh another motion or a question yes I
have a motion uh I would like to move
3 that was the bill relative to um
Administration by the retirement system
of certain Health Care premium
deductions
second when did we hear that that was
the issue as to um whose deductions
should be taken out of a retiree's
benefits first the retirement system or
Das uh after hearing the testimony and
examining um the question it's my
feeling that uh the position of the
retirement system should come first in
deductions all right uh representative
Schultz do you wish to speak to your a
second no I think rep Shu did it very
well okay do that anyone else wish to
speak representative Pearson you were
saying no I uh no I think that she did a
excellent job that's uh I
agree um I actually was convinced by Das
that they had the better case but I've
asked them to provide us with an
amendment that say presents their case
and they
haven't so that's a concern does anyone
else have a a
comment
13 I would agree with representative Shu
and representative Schultz that the most
important thing is that we settle the
issue rather than which way it
discussion seeing none the motion is
ought to pass on House Bill 130 made by
representative Shu when ready the
cler representative Roy yes clerk puts
yes representative Pearson yes
representative
yakovich yes representative leus yes
representative Allegro yes
representative
Bailey yes represent representative
lanzara yes yes representative Santo
naso yes representative
goie
yes representative Shu yes
representative Judy a
we representative
Schmidt
yes representative
Schultz yes representative
fellows yes representative
funno yes representative
groa yes representative O'Brien yes the
chair yes 19
zero any any objections to
consent
okay hearing none representative fellows
do you have a motion I do I'd like to
move itl on HB
Pharmacy is there a second second
representative Pearson second I heard
him I heard him first from the other
people clamoring for
attention second pi why not
representative fellows would you like to
speak to your motion yes Madam chair um
this is at the request of the
sponsor um we when we heard the bill we
recognized that there was a difference
between what we saw in the bill and what
the sponsor thought it said and also the
sponsor has um requested um an itl
because it will give him more time to
work out the differences between the
Board of Pharmacy and the of me
medicine thank you representative do you
wish to speak to your
second I just to go along with that
thank you madam chair the um just the
idea that the various the various
medical boards really do need to work
this out um amongst themselves and and
come before this committee with
something that's that's a little less
than a tur four that's all I have thank
you is there anyone else who wishes to
speak representative scitec didn't we
just want to get rid of
section two for starters the rest of the
bill was okay wasn't
it it I believe the other parts are the
part that aren't quite the same as you
I'm
sorry representative
sh thank you mam chair I I think we
recognize that there are issues with the
bill uh but I'm not going to vote for uh
itl because I think that uh that this is
an issue that needs to be resolved to
the degree that we retain the bill we
could uh that the sponsor and the other
Medical Specialties can work on it with
our blessing and we can have some
involvement as well if we itl it we're
knocking it out for next
year at least potentially thank
repr I to uh was going to go along with
representative Schmidt and work on
retaining this um but after receiving an
email from the sponsor uh recommending
itl I will uh support the inexpedient
legisla
motion thank
you anyone
else I spoke with a sponsor last night
and he said he would leave it up to the
committee after I enter after I engaged
him on the various
aspect that I just spoke to the
committee about he said he would leave
it up to
us okay in that case we are going to
vote on it the motion is itl on House
Bill 444 by representative fellows and
the clerk will call the role
yes CL votes yes representative pearon
representative yakovich
yes representative leus yes repres
representative algro yes representative
Bailey yes representative
lanara yes representative
santoo yes representative goalie yes
representative
sh yes representative Judy
we representative
yes representative Schmid you can vote
Schultz yes representative fellows yes
representative funo yes
representative groa yes representative
O'Brien
yes and the chair yes
consent Madam
chair yes represent sh yes question of
the chair is it not true that uh if the
sponsor comes back with a bill that has
subst stantial changes that he can
introduce that bill in the next
session next year yes yes thank you for
the
clarification as long or present it to
the Senate to start there but it's uh
the things that he that need to be
addressed would make that bill
else well in that case let's break for
lunch we're re oh pearon pearon I am in
full agreement with that motion okay yes
lunch
lunch break for lunch we will resume
back here at 1:30 to continue the
hearing on House Bill
544 I think there's something like 26
people who wanted to wanted to sign up
to speak
so I would suggest to keep the questions
to a
minimum someone else will probably come
along later and answer the questions
also the first half of this hearing was
a little bit intense and somewhat
confrontational which may be okay when
you're talking to the sponsor but these
are all me members of the public so
please let them Express their opinions
however wrong they are and not argue
with them
yes what's
that uh that's a very good question I
will think about I'll announce it before
we start the hearing because some people
tend to uh drag on what was the question
I'm sorry I couldn't hear him whether we
should limit the amount of time each
person speaks okay yeah I think that's
worth
considering okay I I am considering even
as we speak all right in that case don't
yeser that is Rich so get somebody's
attention even if you're gabbling them
down so we will announce the time limit
early uh thank you all and we will see
you back here and the hearing will open
sharp I think is a
I'm not the only one that goes
on it's possible them and then right
away I think problem is if they're still
talking they can't hear you but if
they're
m
I just
now
Madam chair before we start I have a
you or I could just say read the email I
sent you with the question it's
really I can't tell who's in the room or
participants
no I mean I can't tell from the lob
video who is in the room it's very small
computer chis if you click on it it'll
picture
and I do see representative Maguire in
the room but I'm not sure if she can
hear
you I believe everybody can um hear you
uh but we can't hear them if they're
speaking because they're muted still
sure I just had a few minor questions
that I've been asked that only the chair
can answer that's all nothing you know
Earth
shattering okay we are now unmuted thank
you for noticing that and rep and
mentioning that famam we we didn't
realize it uh I got your email the the
answer is I do try to alternate pro and
con but this is the first hearing where
we've actually had enough people from
both sides that we can we can do it most
of the other hearings were very
one-sided uh
and the people that didn't sign up
before 8:00 this morning or signed up
last
time I will be calling
for other other speakers at the end of
the people who have signed up for today
so they will will be have a chance to
speak um thank you so to
the me to the
people here wishing to testify I would
like we're going to try and limit the
amount of time we give to each person so
that every person will have a chance to
speak we want to hear from all of you
but it in order to do that we need to
cut you short if
necessary in in uh in support of that I
will mention that it has been it's a
well-known fact that if you've been
speaking for longer than three minutes a
large number of legislators will start
tuning you out so we want to prevent
that from happening get your points up
front and if necessary we will mute you
after three and a half minutes but
hopefully you will have finished your
testimony by
then
[Music]
and
representative fargan asked to speak
we'll call on him
there
go
yes yes representan please speak glad to
kick glad to kick it off then only six
minutes late
umry my name is resident Timothy Horgan
I represent straford County District Six
which is the towns of Durham and Madbury
so Durham is a home of un8 so this is
particularly large problem if this bill
was passed for a university given that
frankly there's a lot of things in there
they're inimical to its values and also
just playing false but anyway um I'm
opposed HB 544 for many reasons main to
being the fact is racist and anti-free
speech Yes I did say this is a racist
Bill and yes I am virtue signaling but I
have the right to Virtue signal it's
still a free country
um anur sponsors themselves like well
like just about anybody F were
themselves virtue signaling um normally
I lap this bill off but it has to be
taken serious you will not impune the
motives of
anyone to what you believe and what you
know but you may not fault or anyone
okay thank you thank you I would uh well
I would just say I this still would have
racist effect so I'll leave it at that
and I admit that I am virtue signally in
case anybody listening wants to impune
my motives um I'd laugh this bill off
but given you know who majority leaders
at co-sponsor um we have to take it
seriously um certainly uh racism sexism
are no laughing matter racism is theft
sexism is also theft they don't just
steal people's dignity but they even
steal their money because women of
minorities are paid less on the average
and white males for doing the same work
um I I was brought up into Faith which
teaches Racial equality
uh which I prompted by a comment I heard
last week because gu I don't want to
impune his motives but um perhaps many
the committee some of committee may have
heard of it or even belong to it it's a
Roman Catholic Church um I never went
went to perio school but I did graduate
from Christian High School which also
taught Racial equality as well as gender
equality that' be the northv Mount
Herman school so certainly it's possible
I don't think I'm a racist I hope I'm
not I've done unkind things said and
done unkind things which I now know to
be wrong but um it's certainly possible
for me racist both my church community
and my school Community both had and
still have racist within their ranks so
uh my high school is in another state it
probably did a little of any business
with the state of New Hampshire I
haven't checked transparency to go to
see if that's true but I I doubt it does
although if there are similar schools
here in New Hampshire do do business
with state of Hampshire the dasis of
Manchester does lots of business with
the state they would do even more if
certain bills are passed which are not
passing this year they do lots of
business with the state and I'd say most
probably all of the stipulation HB 544
are incompatible with the church's value
in fact I think uh I think the
stipulations HB 54 are incompatible the
values of just about every institution
in the state of New Hampshire including
the business community and um also as I
said and I guess and um I guess also
aside the fact that there's lots of
incorrect facts here in the beginning of
the bill um and it's also probably
totally unenforceable like it because
there's really no way for the state to
know what what sort of interal Personnel
practices um any even a nonprofit or
Corporation or even a business that they
do with and would like and they this
would force them to medal in the Affairs
at just about every every institution
including private businesses that has
any contact with state government
whatsoever so it's uh
it's the lck the other hand there's also
no enforcement mechanism there's no fine
or anything so anyway this is a uh very
bad Bill so I'm sure I'm not the only
person who going to say that so I would
like uh I would urge you to uh itl it as
soon as you know itl it as soon as
possible so thank you if you have to
take any questions should anyone have
them thank you are there questions for
representative
Hy seeing none I call Jim
you
Mr Lindley hello sorry I was uh figuring
out zoom on my phone for the first time
oh okay I unfortunately I'm joining you
from a hotel in Los Angeles today my
name is James Lindsay I
am um an expert in critical race theory
in fact I'm one of the very few experts
in critical race theory that does not
subscribe to the ideology underlying
critical race Theory and I wanted to
testify in support of this bill I think
this bill is a crucial maneuver for
essentially every state especially since
there was an executive order of this
type federally that then was rescinded
by the current sitting president I want
to kind of start my testimony I'll try
to stay brief by saying that I reive
thousands of messages from people all
over the country because I am recognized
as a kind of World level expert in
critical race Theory from parents of
students in schools people in workplaces
begging me for solutions that they can
bring to their workplaces to their
children's schools to try to deal with
the problems that follow from this
ideology a lot of people don't
understand critical race Theory and we
can talk about that briefly in a moment
but I want to talk about the bill itself
first as it's modeled after the
executive order that President Trump
issued in September and it doesn't even
technically ban critical race Theory
it's certainly doesn't ban the teaching
of critical race Theory it certainly
doesn't ban diversity or anti-racist or
racial sensitivity training and people
should be clear about that uh so it's
not shutting down the ability to have
diversity training or education or to
cover these subjects in an academic
manner in school so it should be made
clear on the other hand it does ban
things that are Central to the United
States it bans uh or Central to the
opposite of them is Central to the
United States it bans racial
scapegoating it bans racial stereotyping
it bans racial discrimination it bans
naming the uh country or state in this
case as being intrinsically evil or
racist or sexist it banss the same
things for sex and race um racial
scapegoating sex scapegoating racial
stereotyping sex stereotyping and
discrimination for both uh these are not
things that we really want to try to
bring back into this country we spent a
long time getting away from them the
ideology of critical race Theory begins
from the first assumption that it makes
this is written in all of their
literature you can read it for yourself
for example in Delgado and Stan's
critical race Theory and introduction
which is a standard text book in the
subject it says that it begins from the
assumption that racism and it would be
parallel for sexism is the ordinary
State of Affairs in society it is the
normal science of society it's not an
aberration that boils down in the name
in the words of other Scholars to uh the
question is no longer did racism take
place but rather how did racism manifest
in that situation the people who are
equipped to find the racism that's
apparently hidden in every possible
situation every interaction every uh
student teacher interaction every
employee interaction every boss employee
interaction every single one of those
has racism in it the people equipped to
find it are called critical race
theorists what this training or what
this this bill is supposed to ban is
training people to think this way and
mandating them in their workplaces and
their schools to have to think this way
this is a device
uh dangerous way to reintroduce race
sance and sex sance into our
institutions it's from the thousands of
messages I reive from from panicked
parents and employees all over the
country all the time uh it causes
division it causes hostile working and
learning environments it will set
schools and workplaces up for um
lawsuits where they have created
discrimination and they have created uh
hostile working environment
and it's virtually certain also that it
will open the door to the people that
are providing these trainings from for
being sued for providing a fraudulent
product that does not provide uh what it
claims to provide uh there are already
Attorneys General in some states looking
into how to do that because the evidence
is on is opposite of what these training
materials say that they do so in in that
regard I'll wrap up I think that this is
a very dangerous situation that we find
ourselves in in the United States and in
the state of New Hampshire I'm sure
right now and I think that it is in the
best interest of every state possible to
make a stand on this and say no we are
not going to reintroduce race and sex
scapegoating stereotyping discrimination
or billing our nation or states or
institutions as intrinsically evil
racist or sexist so I have to support uh
this bill as I supported um the
executive order that President Trump
issued in
September thank you thank you are there
any questions from the committee
representative
Pearson thank you for take thank you
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question um historically worldwide has
there ever been a nation that has taught
critical race Theory to its people and
has there and if so what were the
effects of that if you're aware of
any thank you for your question um the
answer to that question is no critical
race theory was be began in the 1970s
but it really was developed in the 1990s
and has only come to prominence in the
in the last decade and it is almost a
holy American invention it was developed
at Harvard Law by Derek Bell and
Kimberly khaw who you can check out the
their scholarship if you want for
yourself and the closest parallel to
what critical race Theory teaches and
preaches it's been installed at the
governmental level is the governor of
South Africa you've seen if you want you
can look up the equity task force that
Governor Insley Washington installated
installed in the um in about a year ago
a little over a year ago in the state of
Washington and they have an entire
section in which they speak that part of
the goal of their task force which is
using the same ideology is to move the
government of Washington in the
direction of the government of South
Africa so if you can look at what's
going on in South Africa right now and
think this is the direction that for my
state this is the direction for the
United States uh that's the closest
parallel that you'll find the critical
race theory is is an American invention
it's it's quite new and uh it has not
yet been installed uh except that it has
kind of taken over in places in the
United States over the past I don't know
eight months or so pretty significantly
leading to president Trump issuing that
order thank you representative Schulz
you had a question yes Madam chair um
thank you for taking my question I think
I know who you are are you the same
James Lindsay that is on Twitter as
conceptual
James yes that's me okay Madam chair I
know that this is going to be a
difficult question but I'm asking it
since he claims to be a national expert
and mean no offense to the committee in
in my question but U Mr Lindsay isn't it
true that you have been
um
uh I guess examined as someone who has
issued death threats against the Jewish
community in prominent Jewish activists
that is not relevant to this bill and I
mean I'll speak to that because it's
false and my name is Dr Lindsay if you
don't mind and you're a math professor
correct not a sociology Professor I am a
PhD in mathematics who's been studying
the relevant academic literature
full-time 16 hours a day most days of
the week for the past three years and
isn't it true you're affiliated with a
national
wh representative Schultz I've muted you
that
that question the answer to that
question is also no I am affiliated with
absolutely nothing of the sort I can
name the organization she's probably
trying to uh insinuate bad things about
to try to impune my motives but that
organization is neither white nor
nationalist it's fact run by a half
Cuban and half of its board is Asian
thank you I just want to say that
because many of the oppon or many of the
proponents of this bill are claiming
that those who oppose this are racist
isn't it important to understand since
this is all ideologically driven if
someone is actually affiliated with a
group that is believed to be by the
Southern Poverty Law Center a white
supremacist group representative Schultz
not necessarily and I think we will not
I do not believe that either the
supporters or the proponents of this
bill are racist and I wouldn't not make
that assumption thank you very much may
I have one moment to say something about
that because it is
Germaine it's
Germaine uh yes so it is important to
understand that one of the one of the
beliefs of critical race theory is that
all criticism of critical race Theory
comes from a place of racism or white
supremacy whether that's intentional or
unintentional when it's unintentional
they call it willful ignorance uh they
they suggest and I can give you a list
of
citations a mile long we could talk
about Barbara Appel bong's being white
being good we could talk about Robin
D'Angelo's white fragility we could talk
about uh Allison Bailey's paper about
privilege preserving epistemic push back
the belief in critical race theory is
that any disagreement with critical race
Theory must come from motives that uh
wish to support uh white supremacy and
racism and in fact they say that people
who benefit from that by virtue of the
color of their skin or because they are
selling out if they races other than say
white or what they term white adjacent
um
have have uh little motivation to
disrupt their own racial Comfort that's
their words and therefore have uh strong
motivation to oppose critical race
theory for self- beneficial ultimately
racist reasons that help to uphold that
alleged racist white supremacy uh system
that they claim as the ordinary
operating system of society so it's very
important to understand that it's
impossible to disagree with critical
race Theory uh without being accused of
being a racist or a white supremacist
and you get used to it after a
while thank you we will attempt not to
insult anyone at this hearing and to all
the participants who are here raising
their hands I have a list of 26 people
who have signed up to speak I will be
calling on them and then I will be
asking for other people who didn't get a
chance only raise your hand if
you're if your name is called and we're
having trouble finding you thank thank
Barnes Mr Ken Barnes yes I'm I'm trying
to unmute and uh make myself visible to
the committee thank you madam chair I
appreciate the opportunity to speak here
um I want to oppose this
bill and I certainly agree with the
chair I do not want to insult anyone and
I will try my best not to um I have to
say uh just with respect to the previous
speaker Mr Dr
Lindsay um I'm not sure what relevance
it really has to even go into a
dissertation about uh what what he
thinks most critical race theorists uh
think
or or say uh I don't think the committ
should should consider what any analysis
of critical race Theory the bill as
proposed does not directly uh challenge
the theory of critical race the the
issue is whether people who someone
thinks uh
propagate is is trying to propagate uh
un unacceptable uh positions is going to
be uh somehow punished or excluded and I
think that's a very dangerous concept
it's dangerous both from a free speech
point of view a democracy point of view
because who knows uh well who's even
deciding if the views being propagated
uh fall into the category of uh being
offensive enough to Warrant uh to to
fall under the the uh orbit of this Bill
and uh who's who's how are the speakers
supposed to know what they can say and
what they can't say without falling
within the Ambit of this bill and uh
that is the essence of what First
Amendment Juris Prudence uh refers to as
a chilling effect on uh American free
speech rights you don't you you chill
you you chill your own speech you you
censor your own self because you don't
want to say anything that's going to be
perceived by the powers that be as uh
being illegal or not not appropriate and
so uh the the full and fair full and
free uh conversation about public issues
and the substance of public issues uh we
don't get to have that full and free
debate because people are self-censoring
and afraid to say things because
somebody might find it offensive uh and
the Supreme
Court and the Very Constitution of the
United States I think takes the position
that we want the most robust discussions
of public issues that we can have and uh
that uh it's left to what some people
some Scholars have called The
Marketplace of ideas to sort out which
ideas were going to listen to uh and and
not not so much listen to We should
listen to everybody I think we should
all respect each other and listen uh
with open open minds to what other folks
have to say um and then we assess what
they what they say and what everybody
else has to say on on the merits on the
substance of what they're discussing and
we don't write anybody off for being you
know too far uh in appropriate too far
out out there to consider what they have
to say and the only limits that the
constitution imposes on the on Free
Speech are the equivalent of shouting
fire in crowded theater if you're going
to be a clear and present present as in
imminent danger of uh causing violence
or Insurrection or something like that
so uh I think the bill is uh again to
use a legal term I'm sorry to use a
legal term but it's over Brad and it's
uh vague and both of those are reasons
why the courts of the United States for
200 and some years have been striking
down uh such statutes thank you very
much and I urge you to uh itl this Bill
thank you representative life laus um
I'm just wondering I'm I'm reading the
bill I don't see where it prohibits
anybody saying anything other than when
they're using uh State money or you know
State and political subdivision money to
promote it so is there somewhere in the
bill where you believe that U you know
General speech or even teaching about
these uh things in a general sense is
prohibited well the bill um to the
extent that it uh cuts off State money
to people who run a foul of the bill and
that means if a teacher in a school
system system and the school system is
is getting State money they lose their
lose the state money if somebody and
it's not clear really who I I think from
the bill um
propagates uh
these ideas that someone thinks are
inappropriate so uh that's if you lose
your funding it if you're threatened
like if you're put in jail you you don't
you can still uh exercise your Free
Speech but you're going to put in jail
if you uh exercise your free speech and
you're going to lose your funding and
the school system relies on its funding
to educate children then that uh that
that t them out to a
Prohibition you don't want to do things
uh somebody's gonna uh slap you down put
you in jail or cut off your
money thank you represent alra can
institutions lose their Public Funding
now for
inappropriate you asking me I take it uh
I uh don't think so um not that I know
of I'd be happy
to entertain the idea of something that
you think might do that but I don't
think uh saying something inappropriate
is currently going to make people lose
thank
you other
questions all right seeing none oh thank
you very much I call thank you madam
chair and members of the committee I
call Carlin
borseno hello my name is Dr Carin bareno
I'm an organizational psychologist and I
live in miramac New Hampshire I'm
testifying today in strong support of HB
544 after last week's hearing
representative CHR Chris Schultz tweeted
the following a bunch of racists in New
Hampshire are promoting a racist bill
that says we should stop pointing out
how dank white supremacy is she also
publicly insinuated that anyone who
disagrees with her
Miss Dr bco I've muted you please do not
attack members of the committee do not
you
she can send us copies of that tweet
though if she wants what's that she can
send us copies of that tweet by email if
she want thank
youy I'm not sure if I was off mute
there but I will say I'm not imputing
her motives I am saying that this she
has made public statements in this
regard and I'm bringing it up to
articulate that nothing is further from
the truth about this bill those are lies
this bill opposes racism it does
precisely the opposite of what people
like representative Schultz are trying
to get you to believe now you just heard
from Dr Lindsay so I won't repeat what
he said about critical race Theory but I
have been working non-stop to understand
this ideology and its impact on
organizations and individuals for the
last two years and here are the
conclusions that I've come to critical
race theory is dangerous and toxic it
teaches people to hate themselves and
inflicts tremendous pain and guilt for
things they are not responsible for let
me be really blun
critical race Theory teaches people that
if you were born white you are
inherently racist and yes representative
Schultz that even includes you the
best-selling book White fragility is one
of the Bibles of critical race Theory
and in it author Robin D'Angelo herself
a white woman confesses that she has
been racist since the womb has been
racist her entire life and will always
be a racist simply because she is born
white it is not a question of if you are
a racist it is is assumed and the only
question is how your racism manifest HB
544 would specifically ban these ideas
from entering into state agencies and
state contractors under the guise of
diversity training now I'm an
organizational psychologist I do
corporate training for a living not all
diversity training is based on critical
race Theory there are wonderful
diversity training programs out there
that have nothing to do with this
ideology and would not be impacted by
this bill the Democrats who are telling
people that this bill would ban
diversity training are lying to you the
bill only addresses trainings that teach
people they are racist because of how
they were born let me tell you how this
training manifests in organizations they
start off by segregating the white
employees from all of the non-white
employees yes under critical race Theory
segregation is a good thing then they
make the white employees confess to
their racism and sometimes even write
letters of apology to non-white
employees even even if their behavior
has not been racist in any way remember
their racism is assumed because of how
they were born and if the white
employees push back or refuse or even if
they just ask questions about why their
organization is making them admit that
they're racists they are in very real
danger of losing their jobs so that is
the choice when this training comes into
organizations you either confess that
you're a racist or you lose your job
that's bad enough but let me give you
evidence and a practical reason to
support this bill there is absolutely no
evidence that training based on critical
race theory is effective none zero zilch
and I know I've looked as an
organizational psychologist if something
is effective in the
work thank you Miss Verano I think we've
we've gotten your testimony is there do
you have a few seconds of highlight that
you want to add well I think that um
there is there is one more thing in that
there is you are going to hear no
testimony today that says this this
training is effective and as a New
Hampshire State resident if my tax
dollars are being spent on something I
want to know that it's actually
effective so critical race Theory
creates more racism not less it is not
going to make organizations fairer more
more open more diverse or any of those
things is going to do exactly the
opposite so I strongly encourage
everyone to support this bill and
protect the people of New Hampshire from
this harmful
ideology thank you are there any
questions
thank you very much Madam chair I wasn't
going to address the comments she
directed at me I did have a genuine
question yes if it's a question ask it
since this bill also addresses gender
and um well gender uh I just wanted to
see if you're the same Carolyn borisenko
who wrote the article in Forge magazine
about the gender pay Gap yes absolutely
I am the gender pay Gap is a and I Dr
bareno thank
you thank you that answers the
Bennett hi thank you to the committee
for hearing this testimony in opposition
to HB
544 my name is Jacob Bennett and I
represent myself today uh for the sake
of full disclosure I would like to note
that I am currently employed as an
adjunct in the education department at
unh
um HP 544 does not identify critical
race theory in its description of
divisive Concepts but seems to be a
fairly transparent reaction to it and
other critical lines of inquiry that
seek to identify and dismantle systemic
racism sexism ableism and
heteronormativity in our society uh and
in any case one of the Bill's
co-sponsors identified CRT by name when
introducing the bill last week as to the
text of the bill it appears to
misconstrue the premise and and purpose
of critical inquiry which does not rely
on essentialist Notions of race or sex
or gender or ability but instead relies
on empirical study of historical
developments and current practice in law
and in broader
Society um critiques of CRT often
indicate that the theory uh is meant to
mean that there are sets of essential
qualities that inhere in white people or
other kinds of people and that those
qualities are oppressive and inescapable
but a more faith interpretation of the
theory is that there is no essential
quality inherent to any race only the
socially constructed systems of meaning
that come to feel true through
generational perpetuation and come to
feel immutable through establishment of
norms expectations and laws the critical
theorists need not be concerned with the
beliefs or best intentions of white men
or people of any background or identity
for that matter in order to establish
the clear record of racist and
misogynist and homophobic brutality that
pervades the EST establishment of this
country the capitalist system which
launched it into Global preeminence and
which persists today in many forms
current intentions good or bad have
nothing to do with the systemic problems
that are the target of critical inquiry
even if overt and clearly articulated
bigotry infuses the foundations of those
historic
challenges instead the critical list is
focused on disperate outcomes that
continue to hinder equity and equal
standing in our society for women for
people of color for queer folks for our
friends and family with different
abilities and we see these disparities
in educational attainments and college
debt burdens as well as in iniquitous
distributions of resources leading to
short earnings and shaky career ladders
even the ability to work remotely and
continue earning during this pandemic
depends a great deal on economic status
and job description as well as race and
gender all told every sector in the
economy has be tou been touched by these
social ills not least of all higher
education where I have been working for
the last 15 years well-respected leaders
in human resources and education have
come to what I believe is a consensus
that we must consider the equity
implications of policy across race sex
gender and ability categories and that
we must confront those implications
headon to do that we must teach each
other and learn from each other how to
conduct the necessary inquiry and enact
the necessary changes required to do so
not only in higher education but across
all disciplines agencies and social
programs this bill suggests that the
real evil is the inquiry into the living
vestages of historic iniquity rather
than the iniquities themselves with this
testimony I've included an article by
the current chair of the Department of
Education studies at Ohio State
University which I believe may serve as
a proper introduction to the CRT with
which I am familiar and hopefully may
serve as a corrective against what seem
to be misconceptions of the theory and
the work it asks us to do in that
article Dr Lorie Patton Davis quotes
from an earlier collaboration of hers
noting that quote the lack of effort to
explicit licitly grapple with racism and
white Su white supremacy is pers a
persistent Trend that is symptomatic of
a society that would rather tiptoe
around the issue of race than directly
address it end quote the point of all of
that is to say that this bill doesn't
named CRT but it is aimed straight at
CRT um but it does so with a
misconstrual and a misconception of what
that means in addition to my concerns
that the bill misconstrues the purpose
and practice of CRT I am also deeply
concerned ConEd that this bill infringes
on the Free Speech rights guaranteed in
the First Amendment of the US
Constitution as well as article 22 of
the New Hampshire Constitution given the
similarities between HB 544 and former
president Trump's executive order
13950 it should be noted that the order
that Trump uh put forward in September
was blocked from imple implementation by
a federal district court injunction on
grounds that it appeared to violate
First Amendment protections as well as
due process rights uh that National
conjunction was sustained on several
grounds including that plaintiffs had
standing to bring pre-enforcement First
Amendment challenge that plaintiffs were
likely to succeed on the merits of their
first amendment claim that plaintiffs
were likely to succeed on the merits of
their due process claim alleging that
the executive order was void for
vagueness I see no reason why the courts
would see this bill any differently in
terms of the very real harm it would do
to speech and due process rights um I
conclude the written testimony which
I've submitted to the te the committee
with a few rhetorical questions I won't
read them out loud here but the basic
premise comes down to this um given that
there will be political appointees uh
under this bill if passed I wonder uh
whether they'll be coming to my class to
make sure that I'm not saying the wrong
things and if I do say the wrong things
I wonder if they're going to fire me on
the spot or just uh start to defund my
program or the department or the college
or the university that I work for um I
don't see how this could F could
functionally be enforced um but that's
the least of my concerns with it I
respectfully register my opposition to
this bill I also have a PhD but you can
call me Jacob if you have any questions
I'm happy to take them thank you uh
representative Alro do you have a
question yes did I understand uh
correctly that uh racism is a
manifestation of capitalism is that what
you said no it's the
opposite I
I please do not argue with the witness
yeah I'm just trying to happy to give
recommendations for texts what's that
Gerald B horn wrote a great book on it
called the counter uh counter
Insurrection would you so then let me
ask it this way would you um please
rephrase what you said um regarding the
relationship between the establishment
of capitalism in this country would not
have happened without the uh uh hundreds
of years of slavery that allowed it to
happen that's what I'm saying thank you
morning morning I'd like to uh speak uh
on behalf of in support of this bill
rather um if you look at the language in
the bill it's quite clear all it does is
say that you can not uh stereotype
scapegoat or demean individuals on the
basis of race and sex uh this is the
basic moral takeaway of the 14th
Amendment and of the 1964 Civil Rights
Act uh critical race Theory as it's
implemented in institutions um actually
does all of those things it stereotypes
scapegoats and demeans it traffics in
Notions of race essentialism uh it
promotes harmful and divisive
stereotypes based on inborn
characteristics um it also creates a
hostile working environment and would
put the state at risk of legal action uh
and finally uh I think that it's very
clear that these are also violations in
many cases of the Civil Rights Act I'm
the director of the center on wealth and
poverty at Discovery Institute I'm a
contributing editor at City Journal
magazine um and a visiting fellow this
year at the Heritage Foundation uh I've
studied critical race Theory I've done
the investigative reporting and I'd like
to just share a few examples of what
happens uh in the real world uh as these
programs are implemented that this bill
seeks to prevent I reported on um the
Sandia National Laboratories which
produces designs and produces the
nuclear weapons arsenal of the United
States government uh they recently took
white male Executives uh and then forced
them in a training session uh to
deconstruct their white male identity it
said that being a white male is
analogous to the KKK to White
supremacists and to lynching and then
forc them to apologize uh for their
inborn traits uh and write letters of
apology uh and in the abstra ract to
women and people of color uh for the way
that they were born um in education
these programs are deeply harmful I've
reported on recently a story where first
graders in California were forced to
deconstruct their racial and sexual
identities and then rank themselves
according to their power and privilege
telling F some first graders that they
were the oppressors and some first
graders that they were the oppressed
I've also reported uh on a story
recently in New York City where a public
middle and high school sent a email to
White parents telling them that uh they
had to do white identity work um and
that the highest goal as a white person
should be to become become a quote white
traitor and eventually advocate for
quote white abolition uh this is
language that applied to any other group
would be considered a euphemism for
elimination um this kind of rhetoric is
deeply divisive it hurts people and and
finally uh it's actually in in PR
practice deeply uh condescending and and
patronizing towards uh people of color
um critical race Theory argues in many
training sessions that I've documented
and reported on that traits of
rationalism
individuality logic and punctuality are
manifestations of white supremacy uh
implying that uh African-Americans and
Latinos Asians and Native Americans are
somehow not able to exhibit the
qualities of rationality or punctuality
uh or even logic um this kind of
ideology is deeply corrosive at its core
it's fundamentally racist and again the
language of this bill says you cannot be
racist or sexist you cannot degrade
demean or stereotype people on the basis
of race or sex uh anyone who votes for
this bill uh would be basically saying
that we support and will will allow uh
racism and sexism to proliferate through
the institutions um it's a very simple
moral question uh don't be uh kind of
Taken astray uh by the very verbose
academic language of some of my
opponents supporting or opposing this
bill um it's very simple look what
happens in practice um and uh please
stand up uh for the right thing in
defense of civil rights uh in defense of
logic and rationality uh and in defense
of treating people equally no matter how
thank you there any questions for
[Music]
the there being none uh witness is
excuse thank
you
Mr beler if you're in the attendees
raise your hand if you're what's huh
what's the next one
[Music]
smel
I I can't hear him that's okay I I just
him
now I I I can't hear him or see him now
yeah I know neither can we I'm working
on
it I keep trying to promote him the
time okay Mr V I'll meet yourself and
you
ahead we don't hear you Mr
Bel
me try without the
headset can you hear me now yeah we hear
you now go ahead thank you uh
fundamentally what this bill seeks to
prohibit is the mandatory training of
critical theory in government I could
open with the fact that critical theory
is of a Marxist origin that it
explicitly rejects the civil rights
movement and equality under law I could
describe how it is not in the liberal
tradition and these things are true
however Americans have the right to hold
these beliefs and they have the right to
espouse them that is their protected
First Amendment right what we're here to
talk about is workplace
training but when people are trained in
ideology they are not learning a skill
the proper term for training in ideology
is
indoctrination while anybody may as is
their right hold these views they do not
have the right to force others to hold
these
views they do not have the right to
violate others freedoms of speech of
Association or of religion by compelling
others to pledge fty to their
ideology
or the uh I'm sorry to make confessions
to the sinfulness of their their skin
color or for America at large make no
mistake critical theory trainings are
often segregated by skin color and
indeed so is the content of these
trainings while some segregated groups
are often made to confess their own
racism other groups are taught of the
evils of the other group here are a
couple real world
examples the US Department of Homeland
Security hosted a training on
microaggressions micro inequities and
micro assaults where employees white
employees only were told that they had
been socialized into oppressor
roles this indoctrination isn't limited
to
workplaces in a recent Elementary School
in copertino California forced a class
of third graders to deconstruct their
racial identities then rank themselves
according to their power and privilege
again they forc third graders to rank
themselves B based on skin
color there are countless more examples
of this uh people having this ideology
thrust upon them in both public and
private sectors and Nationwide this
ideology and specifically these types of
trainings are rightly leading to
lawsuits under the theory of hostile
work
environment they may also be seen as
violations of civil
rights as such these indoctrinations in
New Hampshire are liable to put
substantial sums of taxpayer money at
risk through uh harassment of state
employees it should be noted that the
promotion of diversity and inclusion not
rooted in critical theory is possible it
is in keeping with America's liberal
tradition and it's perfectly acceptable
and this bill does nothing to prohibit
this further the idea that there isn't
already speech limitations in the
workplace is false we already prohibit
harassment based on sex based on race
and based on gender this just clarifies
that these sorts of trainings when
directed at People based on critical
theory are also forms of
harassment um that's it thank you for
your
questions seeing none you excuse thank
you for your testimony thank
you this time I'd like to call in Aon
pachic I'm saying that correctly oh Mr
chair it looks like uh representative
Schmidt had a question oh it just popped
up me um is the witness still here yes
ahead thank you Mr beler can you tell me
where in New Hampshire at any level
critical race tra training critical race
in the state of New Hampshire I'm not
specifically aware of where it's being
taught I do know these are commonly done
in government trainings however as well
such thank you so you're not aware of
are are you aware of have you done any
study of New Hampshire with regard to
this
subject not specifically in New
Hampshire as far as where it's being
taught here no I am aware of many other
individual locations where it's being
done the same exact
Theory thank you that answers the
question thank you
Mr any further
questions okay now at this time of
calling Aon kind
check okay can you hear me yeah go ahead
all right much of what I want to say uh
first of all Aon pich I live at33
downroad in Hollis um much of what I
wanted to say has already been
eloquently
all right can you still hear me
something was happening with my zoom
screen there start over again we're
you're all set okay good so um so again
Aron and Kasich I'm at 133 Dow Road in
Hollis and uh uh much of what I wanted
to say has already been eloquently
presented to you so I'm not going to
repeat it in the interest of time but I
have just U four five quick little
bullet points one is this bill HB 544
which I'm speaking in favor of um if you
if you read it and think about what all
those points say in there it actually
supports
non-discrimination right what it's a to
do is to pre pre uh prevent critical
race theory in the way the previous
speaker just described as being shoved
into our school system we don't have a
problem with that in this area there are
Pockets where I believe there are
problems uh that some of the critical
race Theory could be applicable in terms
of solving them we don't have that
problem here so you know this to me
boils down to are we going to waste tax
dollars on something like this to solve
a problem that doesn't exist
um secondly is the critical race Theory
that's being proposed and implemented
around the country as we've already
heard as well and I I won't talk much
about it promotes
divisiveness and that's the exact exact
opposite of what we want to do in our
school systems the Educators should be
teaching math science English
non-revision revisionist History
government that's what they should be
doing that's what we pay them to do with
our tax schols they should be teaching
how to think not what to think if
they're teaching what to think they have
failed as
Educators and that's all I have for
questions there be none um Witnesses
excuse thank you for your testimony I'm
going to call on please forgive me if I
put you your name Asma
elone you have to
unmute
hello can you hear me yes we do thank
you yeah hi uh my name is Asma aluni and
I am speaking against this bill very
strongly um because we cannot as a state
expect to work towards achieving
equality without first acknowledging and
addressing the biases that are deeply
rooted in the fabric of ourselves
our communities our state and our nation
right unconscious racism is real I am a
woman of color who is Muslim and wears
hijab I have been to schools
organizations and churches and college
classrooms to share how people like me
are targeted in our experiences with
racism in this country for example the
fact that there has been research that
documents that Arabs and Muslims are
overwhelmingly negatively portrayed in
media and oftentimes targeted under the
security apparatus right overwhelmingly
images of us are negative and
stereotypical in nature like being
violent or that women are submissive or
oppressed this is not only in the media
but it's also in education and the
Department of Homeland Security with the
the um targeting of innocent Arabs and
Muslims through surveillance being
arrested without given due process are
all examples of how certain groups
groups of people experience racism today
and in this bill it clearly states um
there's a line in there that
divisiveness is saying that New
Hampshire or the United States is
inherently um racist when I share ways
people like me experience racism it
creates a space for something to be done
about it and for people to learn how
their actions can be racist we're human
we learn and we do better I can tell
that together we can do something about
it because when we're not actively
fighting racism in ourselves and in our
society racism will continue and will
continue to harm our Our Lives yes
people sticking their middle finger at
me when I do nothing but walk down the
street that's bad but also when my
family is banned from coming to the US
right through the Muslim ban that is
also racism racism is institutionalized
as well so when I'm pulled aside at the
airport and get checked for bomb
material right um just to make sure that
you know I'm not violent or whatever
that's institutionalized racism I have a
right to call it out when Arabs and
Muslims are targeted by the FBI for
surveillance and forc to spy in our
communities or lose immigrant status
that is institutionalized racism and I
have a right to call it out so yes
people telling me to go back home I
don't belong here does hurt me but it's
it's only because things that our our
government our institutions also promote
that allows these things to happen
through movies through the media right
these negative images of people like us
people like me and so many other people
of color go through racism in this
country and we must as a nation address
racism and classism and sexism and
ableism so that many other things can
stop that are dividing our nation under
this bill no one would be able to
benefit in making the connections of the
historical and modern forms of racism
that continue to plague our communities
for representative jasf Osborne who who
introduced this if you hear this I want
to say to you that our experiences are
very real they may not be true for you
because they do not happen to you but
know that racism is alive and true for
us and that it is institutionalized to
call it divisive to name our experiences
um is to ignore the fact that what is
really divisive is the continuation of
racism and classism and sexism we must
come together as a people black white
brown all of us to be able to name what
is happening in our communities so that
we can come together and dismantle all
these oppressive systems that plague our
communities and we want to be able to
dismantle that together so this bill
undermines that effort to Foster
diversity and inclusion and it must be
stopped at all costs please do itl this
bill um thank you for your testimony um
representative leakas has a question um
thank you and thank you for taking my
question um
what I'm wondering is given um the part
at the end of the bill General
Provisions especially part one and two
um what is there in this bill that would
present prevent you from you know
talking about um including in schools
your experiences and similar experiences
that other people have had and talking
about clearly yes thank you
representative clearly the the bill
itself if you look there is language
that can be used it looks all pretty
it's wrapped up in beautiful cloth but
it is a dangerous bill because there is
language in there that can stop people
from allowing me to say we have an
inherently racist Society we we need to
work on that and that's the problem with
this bill it looks all nice but there
are things that can cause really serious
even against our constitution you know
we have a right to free speech we have a
right to name what's happening in our
communities and this is going to be used
against us this is not the way we need
to be moving as a society and we clearly
know why bills like this are are being
introduced we know that Trump introduced
it so I I don't think I need to say
anymore this is a dangerous
bill um I I'd question you against
assuming the motives of people that have
put the bill in or support it but thank
you for your
answer um represent
Schulz thank you Mr chair U Miss El
honeyi I I want I hope I pronounced your
name correctly um I I want to make sure
I understand you correctly because I I
hear you say that you're an expert in
presenting on these topics so are you
saying that it is helpful to
dispelling um I guess bigotry if we want
to group all of them together that it's
helpful to point out
differences and does pointing out are
you saying that pointing out these
differences isn't racist and helps us
diffuse
racism yes representative Schultz you
are absolutely correct when I'm saying
that it is important to name how
different communities are facing or
moving about in our communities and to
stop racism racism we have to be able to
name it so yes in order to end racism we
have to be able to say this is the way
we're treated differently and so um yes
absolutely we must actually name the
difference so that we can fix it so that
we can live in a more Equitable Society
but people want to shut that
conversation down and want to say
whenever we want to talk about the ways
that we are being harmed as as being
divisive the divisiveness is to our
lives what we've been facing that's
divisive we need to come together as a
community and say together we're going
to fight this thank
testimony I'm now going to call call on
Spot hello thank you good afternoon uh
and again thank you for the opportunity
to speak my name is James bomersbach I
am a licensed psychologist a resident of
New Hampshire and the chair of the
legislative committee for the New
Hampshire Psychological Association the
organization represents psychologists in
the
state um I want to offer the following
testimony and hopes that it will
convince the committee to reject this
bill uh the requirements and assertions
set forth in this bill are out of line
with current psychological theories on
racism sexism bias and discrimination uh
the bill would serve to reinforce
harmful social structures while claiming
to do the exact opposite psychologists
strive to adhere to to a professional
code of ethics and to advocate for those
ethical principles when doing so would
Aid the mental health of others that is
what I hope to represent here
today in talking about race and gender
it is important to differentiate between
the goals to which we as a society
Aspire and the reality in which we live
this bill's language appears to push
people away from propagating racist
beliefs a noble Pursuit uh however it
would also prevent discussion of real
and ongoing problems in our society
let's take the examples which
are within the bill although not
expressly referenced um of white
privilege and male privilege now
privilege is the phenomenon whereby
individuals of certain racial
backgrounds or certain genders uh have
benefits that are afforded to them in
society that are not afforded to others
who lack that
privilege uh a part of the challenge of
discussing and overcoming privilege uh
is that there may be those people who
have privilege who assume that this is
true for everyone that they can that
everyone has these privileges um rather
than recognizing that as something that
has been granted them because of
qualities of their birth rather than
qualities of their
character uh in truth examples of white
privilege and male privilege are
consistently identified in social
science research uh examples include
disparities in evaluations of homes uh
in selection or rejection of job
applications in treatment within Health
Care settings and perhaps most visibly
in recent years in responses from law
enforcement and criminal justice
agencies
now an important part of the process of
dismantling privilege is honest
recognition of its influences on all of
our lives and how it has aided
individuals who have privilege and how
it has harmed those who do not
unfortunately all too often people can
become defensive when confronted with
the reality that they have benefited
from privilege especially when they
might not even recognize that they have
that privilege in the first place uh
they may deny that privilege is real and
that it is ultim Ely harmful to everyone
discussion and training about privilege
and other so-called divisive Concepts is
therefore not about advocating for race
or gender biases as some would suggest
um it is instead about recognition and
helping others recognize that these
biases still exist throughout our
society a law that would prevent open
and free discussion of privilege and
bias would only serve to maintain the
existences of these biases we must not
diminish the lived experiences of those
who have been harmed by privilege we
must not build barriers that could
help uh this bill also includes
discussion of
scapegoating uh you know this is my BR
testimony I'm going to just move ahead a
little bit here for the sake of
time but I would encourage all of you to
read the the remainder of my testimony
I'll finish with this as psychologists
we recognize that we have a duty to
recognize the importance of advocating
for justice and for respect for people's
rights and dignity we recognize that
social institutions in the United States
and in New Hampshire have a historical
record of treating individuals
differently based on race gender and
other personal characteristics as a
society we have progressed toward a more
equal and free Society however we
recognize that this effort is not
complete and we must always continue to
work towards our guiding principles
limiting discussion of controversial
topics and treating racism and sexism as
relics of a past age only serve to
prevent us from making further progress
therefore I strongly urge each Committee
Member to vote down this proposal I
would hope that the discussion today
would encourage each of us to further
explore our own experiences with race
and sex-based discrimination and to lead
us to ask ourselves what more we can do
to overcome them thank
Schmidt thank you Mr chairman thank you
Mr bmers back
uh one of the things we
are receiving on this committee is a lot
of emails from parents who are very
concerned about things that their
children are being taught I'm wondering
whether you're personally involved with
or your Association is involved with
counseling for school systems which are
attempting to address
actual cultural and
historical
phenomena in this state I'm not
concerned about other states this state
um that
trying of others of being non-racist and
non judgmental and so
forth are you involved with attempting
to assist school systems in designing
programs that will be effective in and
not just leaving it up to the teachers
uh ideas or but giving them expert
background training so that they teach
well and and and are beneficial to their
students thank you for the question I
must say I am not personally um familiar
with being I'm not able to answer that
question for you today although I will
be happy to uh speak with within my
organization and uh to email you a
response more specifically uh I'm not
aware of any psychologists in in the
state who
are
um doing more of a of a role as a school
psychologist I know that they exist I
just had an opportunity to speak with
them on this matter um so I'd have to
find some more information and get back
email follow up yeah go ahead
follow thank you so do you have any
personal clients patients who uh have
approached you uh because their
children um or perhaps they brought in a
child who has been confronted in the
school
systems uh with uh teaching that they
found uh harmful or threatening or
disorienting uh because the parents that
are writing to us are very concerned
about they the the ones that mention
anything they mention critical race
theory is this being taught or used
Hampshire so uh I am not in private
practice myself I am a forensic
psychologist I work for I work on behalf
of the state conducting competency and
other mental health violations in the
court system uh again I so I cannot
answer I can't say that I have any
clients uh so I can't speak to whether
or not people are are coming in with
concerns about critical race
Theory again I would have to open that
question up to members of my
organization and then get back to you
hopefully in a couple of
days please do thank
you thank you uh there being no further
questions I see um the witnesses
appreciate your testimony thank you at
this point I will now call on Dan
Richard you have to unmute yourself sir
there you go thank you very much thank
you members of the committee for the
opportunity to speak my name is Dan
Richards and I live in Etna New
Hampshire I also run a company that
employs over 200 people that is lo that
is located in Lebanon and headquartered
in Lebanon New Hampshire I come to you
today to support and respectfully
request you vote in favor of HB
544 my family and our fellow citizens in
New Hampshire do not believe racist IND
discriminatory practices are acceptable
under any circumstance
and this bill would forever enshrine
that belief in New Hampshire law my wife
Melissa and I have two young children
our daughter is in second grade and our
son will be entering kindergarten next
year at
sa70 my wife and I are deeply concerned
about what is being taught in the
trainings that are being conducted in
our district but I don't come here just
for myself and my family I also come
here today out of concern for the dozens
of my employees children who are also
being educated in New Hampshire let me
give you an example of what is h
happening this past spring a course was
taught entitled exploring whiteness and
becoming an anti-racist activist that
contained blatantly racist and
anti-American topics the core syllabus
which I have will be submitted following
my testimony for your review a brief
summary of the objectionable content
includes number one a quiz that asks the
rise of white supremacy was tied most
directly to a Indian Removal B slavery C
the Declaration of Independence D the US
Constitution or E ancient Greece the
answer demanded C the Declaration of
Independence number two a 2hour and
13-minute lecture given by an individual
named Tim Wise Mr wise's lecture
includes frequent and repeated racist
and anti-American statements including a
rich white people telling workingclass
white people that their problem is other
workingclass people who just so happen
to be Browner than themselves that is
the whole history of America B let's be
clear our ancestors from Europe were The
Losers of their
societies C Liberty and freedom you
think we believed in that what history
book have you been reading we didn't
believe in that number three a one-hour
in 23 minute lecture from Robin D'Angelo
whose entire talk is consumed with how
all whites are quote unquote fragile due
to their culpability and complicity in
our quote racist system close quote
number four we've been told by a member
of our elementary school leadership team
that they will be using quote
achievement debts accumulated over
hundreds of years to teach for social
transformation close quote to accomplish
this Equity diversity and inclusion
trainings have been conducted for months
I'm told partially funded by state
grants for for all teachers faculty and
staff my opinion these kinds of
teachings and trainings are as
objectionable as they are false
inflammatory and yes racist they have no
place in our New Hampshire schools and
in the training programs of New
Hampshire companies I'd like to conclude
by saying I'm the son of a marine
veteran my grandfather and several great
unes served in the armed forces and
fought the access during World War II
some of my ancestors were rounded up
sent to camps and exterminated my family
knows what racism and white supremacy
looks like we fought and we have died to
defend the United States and the
egalitarian principles for which it
stands it is sad commentary about our
times that we need House Bill 544 but
the reality is we do our children
deserve to be taught the history of this
nation for all of its greatness and all
of its flaws they do not deserve to be
indoctrinated with hatred not only of
themselves but also of those who choose
to love this country
I humbly request you pass House Bill 544
so I can send my kids to school free
from racism discrimination and racial
much thank you representative Alro you
have a question yeah I'm I'm asking this
because I think you may have asked
answered a question that was asked a
couple of times earlier uh in the uh
hearing if I understood you correctly I
want to make sure I understood you
correctly
you are indicating that this uh ideology
is indeed being taught in New Hampshire
schools is that correct yes ma'am that
Moore
question of the chair while we're
waiting I was I had my hand up to ask
question he's still here ask your
question thank you madam chair um I'll
be brief I found that uh those questions
that you read I found that interesting
so the one by the way I'm also the child
of a marine so yay love that um that's
irrelevant though to today but um my
question is so with that questionnaire
you said you were going to send it to us
that's great I want to see it did you
ask at least in the first one did you
ask why they felt that the indeep uh
Declaration of Independence was a sign
of
racism to help understand why that might
be a moment that can be uh a teachable
moment you could
say uh Well ma'am the uh document that I
referred to is actually not a
questionnaire it's actually the syllabus
for the course oh that yeah so it's so
it's not a questionnaire it's a syllabus
and that is one of the documents the
quiz is one of the documents that was
actually used in the
course because I had this conversation
myself and it was Illuminating to me to
hear from an African-American why the
Declaration of Independence in
celebrating the 4th of July could be
difficult to a descendant of slaves so
anyway just throwing that out there but
ma'am
yourself I did not have a question I am
listening in today because I am looking
to move to New Hampshire and so this is
seriously concerning to my S as an
African-American woman and as a woman
who is looking to raise children in New
concern sorry I had to step
thank you so uh as you probably are
aware we're having technical
difficulties I can some of the witnesses
I can hardly even hear anything that
they're saying is this problem being
worked
on is anyone else having this
problem no no
I you may have a weak internet
connection or you might have a u your
it's not a volume issue it's a
distortion
issue
T um fine Madam chair I will say there
have been a few speakers that uh from
time to time their uh speeches have been
broken
up that no doubt happens all right
bonette thank you madam chair can I can
I be seen I want to make sure this is
working can be seen you can you can be
heard wonderful thank you so much uh
Madame chair and the members uh of this
committee my name is jel B I'm the legal
director uh for the ACLU of New
Hampshire we oppose this bill I did
submit some testimony um earlier this
morning um on why we oppose this bill uh
and I just want to make two brief points
um the first
is that uh this bill uh if enacted would
likely bar the implementation of some of
the recommendations made by the C the
governor's Commission on law enforcement
accountability community and
transparency so I just wanted to flag
that that's highlighted in more detail
in our testimony and the specific
recommendations that would be negatively
impacted by this bill um and the second
point that I wanted to make um just has
to do with the constitutionality um of
uh HB 544 this bill in my view violates
the First Amendment uh now to be clear I
I personally um strongly uh believe that
systemic racism exists in our society
but I you know I recognize from this
hearing today that many dis agree with
me and that's okay uh that difference of
opinion and the debate around it is I
really think the Hallmark of American
democracy and the first amendment
protects that difference of opinion
where the government I don't think um
should have the power to tell
individuals and in this case State
contractors how they should speak within
their companies and that is why I
believe this bill is problematic I think
this bill is unconstitutional because it
requires every single individual or
company that enters into a state
contract uh in the future to not provide
trainings on these types of issues even
on the contractor's own time and even on
their own dime using their uh own money
whether one believes that systemic
racism exists or not uh the problem I
think with this bill is that it really
picks aside right and then leverages the
government's Financial Resources to
suppress this type of private speech
about race and gender among State
contractors and their employes um for
those who dislike um this type of speech
on kind of quote divisive topics uh and
I know there are many I believe that the
solution to this really is to not
suppress it among these private actors
but to counter it through counter speech
um I think it's also worth noting this
was highlighted in earlier testimony um
this afternoon that a preliminary
Nationwide injunction was imposed on
portions of a prior executive order um
that's akin to this legislation and I
attached that decision uh to my email to
the committee uh and what the court
concluded in that case is that the
executive orders Provisions uh similar
Provisions here um concerning
contractors likely violated the First
Amendment quote the government's
interest is outweighed by the effect of
the impermissible reach of the executive
order on plaintiff's freedom to deliver
the diversity training and advocacy that
they deem necessary to train their own
employees and the service providers in
the communities in which they work using
funds unrelated to the federal contract
and I think this this bill really does
have in my view that same problem so for
those two reasons we oppose this bill
and I want to thank the committee for
its
time representative Pearson you have a
question question I
do uh Ju Just for CLA you said you were
an attorney for the
ACLU yes I work uh I'm I'm the legal
director for the ACLU of New Hampshire I
actually uh work one block away from the
state house right behind CVS on Main
Street okay great thank you for the
clarification in your tenure as a as an
attorney for the ACLU have you have you
ever filed or is the ACL of New
Hampshire ever filed a lawsuit using the
term hate speech in any way shape
form no I don't gosh I don't think so I
mean hate speech is not a really a legal
term right uh it's not necessarily you
know one of the categories even of
unprotected speech so I don't think at
least in my
practice uh it's something that it's
really a term that I have used in my
work in
court thank
you representative Roy thank you for
taking that question um
okay so first my question is you
discussed how this would impact private
company
contract didn't touch ones ACL have a
position on
question sorry we microphone challenged
here
um my question was he uh said the
opinion of the ACLU regarding um private
contractors a work for the state but I'm
interested in the aclu's position on
Schools whereby students um are mandated
by law to attend and therefore they
don't have a choice or the ability to
counter this speech what is the position
of the AC on
that yeah I uh I haven't thought about
that issue I'm not sure how pervasive
this type of uh teaching is in New
Hampshire um we uh I don't think have
taken a position on whether or not uh
this type of instruction should be
mandated in schools I can tell you that
where we have been more active when
where I have been more active uh is to
what extent uh implicit bias training
should be involved in law enforcement
training right that was one of the
issues that was squarely presented
before uh before Lea and that's
something that that we've advocated uh
for we think that uh is important but
that really again is ultimately the
choice of the employer in this case law
enforcement to decide whether that's
appropriate for their officers and
something that um they should be using
to Foster trust uh with the community so
I didn't mean to Pivot I I don't really
have a direct answer to your question uh
representative Roy I I don't think it's
something that at least I've taken a
context um and just a quick followup um
sure you're the second or third witness
who's mentioned the uh the court case
against the Trump executive order uh
just to be clear that that was a a
district court case that issued that um
that issued that correct it wasn't
um Court no you're absolutely correct uh
representative Roy I believe it was the
it was the federal judge in the district
of California so you're but you're
exactly right no it wasn't an appell at
circuit court or the US Supreme Court
you I call Cheryl
yourself let's see okay there you are
can you hear me yes
okay um I'm here today speaking as a
private citizen uh
although I served on the New Hampshire
commission for human rights for 13 years
and I've also been an
educator uh at um a university here in
and it seems to me a lot of what I
wanted to say is has already been said
um I I
oppose uh House Bill
um it would
um it seems make the department of
administrative Services the Arbiter of
of teaching plans and determining what
kind of speech is acceptable about
discrimination um there's a couple key
parts of the proposed bill um that I I
think are overly
Broad and um many of the the topics that
we're talking about teaching of history
and training about civil rights are
going to be by their very nature
controversial there are going to be
differences of opinion and we we don't
want to have you know a a specific
bureaucratic agency trying to pre-screen
all of the teaching plans and and
um determine what's going to be
acceptable within the
classrooms uh at the University level
um or at the the secondary
level I hope that you'll um oppose this
bill I don't think that the bill is is
necessary or likely to to
promote um human rights in New
Hampshire we've had a
anti-discrimination bill here for over
years the commission for Human Rights
was created as a civil rights agenc
um by the legislature it was a a
bipartisan effort and um
that agency plays a key role in in
working toward ending discrimination it
also has as part of its Mission the
educational Outreach and um I think that
this is problematic in terms of freedom
of speech rights both at the state level
and at the national level so I'll I'll
end there and urge you to um vote
against this
Bill thank you representative Pearson
you have a question I do you said you
you were taught at the University
level yes I did thank you ma'am uh you
wear on page
four at line 21 says nothing in this
chapter chapter shall be construed to
prohibit discussing as part of a larger
course of academic instruction the
divisive Concepts listed in RSA 10 C1
section 2 in an objective Manner and
without endorsement so the idea did I
hear you correctly that that you're
arguing that that this bill prevents
universities from having the discussion
because what I'm reading on page four
ISS
otherwise no I think your other um
speakers today have argued that it will
have a chilling effect on speech as a
matter of fact I've I've heard from
faculty members who just are already
concerned about this bill and whether
it's going to be passed and how it might
impact how they're teaching in the
classroom um and that does lead to to
people self-censoring and I think would
be likely to to have that kind of
chilling
effect thank you Miss Shirley other
questions okay my list of people who
wanted to speak doesn't seem to relate
very well to the attendees list so if
you are interested in speaking please
raise your hand and I'll there's 10
people already I guess we don't have any
[Music]
them
okay
Carpenter you have to unmute yourself
and then pleas speak
[Music]
sorry madam chair were you talking to me
my zoom feed cut out so I didn't hear if
my name was called we were thank you
please uh we're asking for people to
testify please do
so my apologies again hi hi everyone
thank you so much Madam chair for
calling on me and good afternoon to the
representatives and attendees my name is
Christine Carpenter and I'm a resident
of Windam New Hampshire I have a
master's degree from the University of
Cambridge and I'm a few months away from
earning a law degree from the University
of Pennsylvania Law School and I'm a
product of the New Hampshire Public
School System having spent 12 years in
the Windham School District and the
better part of a decade in higher ed I
have a fair deal of experience in the
process of being taught this is the lens
through which I came to offer my view of
this bill today
this proposed legislation causes me a
great deal of concern because it
essentially hamstrings teachers access
to the resources necessary to better
understand the individuals sitting in
their classrooms and therefore their
ability to effectively teach their
students my central issue with the bill
is this as one of or actually I think
several of the earlier speakers noted
the bill doesn't only address teachings
rooted in critical race Theory although
that may have been its original
intention and we can sit here today and
discuss the merage
and the flaws with critical race Theory
truly endlessly clearly just judging by
the number of testifying that we've had
there's a lot to talk about there but
all of that aside what this bill does is
it essentially limits an overly broad
category of topics of conversation in
teacher trainings in teacher contracts
in Grant applications Etc so in non
constitutional law terms that just means
it hampers more topics than it
explicitly aims to so if you want to
write a bill prohibiting the teaching of
critical race theory in schools and the
training of teachers around critical
race Theory then by all means draft one
and let's have a conversation about that
on the Merit specifically but that is
not what this bill achieves in its
current form so to illustrate this by
way of example in the medical field
doctors are more likely to misdiagnose
an illness in someone who is Black than
someone who is white to varying degrees
based on the illness in a car crash
women are 73% more likely to be killed
or seriously injured because data
gathered from Crash simulations and the
Crash Test Dummies themselves are
statistically modeled based on men
collectively individuals that identify
as something other than heterosexual are
more likely to experience physical
violence and verbal abuse as a result of
their sexuality and children in this
population are twice as likely to
attempt or to commit suicide before they
turn 18 than their heterosexual peers in
the context of covid-19 which is why I
can speak to you today from my desk in
Pennsylvania black Americans account for
13% of the US population and yet 24% of
coronavirus deaths these statistics have
something important in common under the
definition section 2 C and four of Bill
544 all of these statistics and the
issues that they represent could be
prohibited for Teacher trainings now
could is doing a lot of work here I
understand that that might not have been
the intention of the drafters nor the
intention of anyone who has come out to
speak in favor of this bill today but
that is what the bill can be weaponized
to achieve this bill can be used as a
tool to resist teacher trainings deny
Grant applications and curtail teacher
contracts based on Extreme political
views that are themselves divisive this
would also be done so out of a misnaming
and a misidentifying of the aim that the
bill purports to achieve I'm referring
specifically to the Bill's insistent
limiting of discussions and trainings
around unconscious biases so for example
the doctor that misdiagnoses a patient
because medical textbooks fail to note
differing signs and symptoms in a
disease for people of color is not
consciously racist nor is the scientist
that designed the craft test simulations
consciously sexist but the reality and
the actual implications of their work
nevertheless has racist and sexist
outcomes these outcomes matter because
people die as a result and crucially to
my point people die in systemically
unequal ratios people of color die more
of the time from misdiagnosis sorry
misdiagnosis than white people women die
more of the time in the same kind of car
accent than
men so under your definition of divisive
these objective realities would be
prohibited topics of conversation in the
realm of public education training in
New Hampshire moreover this bill if it
existed as company policy at an
automobile manufacturer or a hospital
would prevent those who work in their
field from being able to be made aware
of this problem so that they can repair
it the sorry I said Thank you you've
you've exceeded what we consider our
normal limit could you will just wrap it
up quickly I would appreciate it
absolutely apologies chair so the bottom
line here today is I'm not here to talk
about the Constitutional implications of
this bill although I do as other
speakers have said want to note that
there are many I'm here as a citizen of
New Hampshire that is concerned about
students ability to learn from a
productive
dialogue and in light of that I think it
is fervently important that this bill be
opposed and I am happy to have future
comment or discussion uh if you I think
have my email from the login if anyone
would like it I really really think it's
important to continue communicating
about these issues but in its current
form this bill does not achieve
something that is beneficial for New
Hampshire Ed Educators it's students or
frankly it's alumni that need to go out
and operate in a world in which these
issues are real and these issues have
implications that matter that we have to
engage with whether our public school
education in New Hampshire will teach us
about them or not thank you very much
will you answer a question
happily laus uh thank you madam chair
thank you for taking the question um I
mean you're you're con can you help me
understand what part of the bill do you
think would prevent discussions of
things like the facts that there's
problems with you know the the things
that are parameters for Designing car
tests or or some of the other things you
mentioned which seem to be just you know
facts about accidents and and and the
reasons why um there may be
disproportionate effects I'm not seeing
anything in the bill that would do that
what what do you think actually result
in that sure so specifically if you look
at the definition sections 2 C and four
um I can talk about other sections of
the definition as well but just to give
you by way of example what the bill gets
at is issues surrounding unconscious
biases and suggesting that they're
inherent to the way that groups of
people live their lives simply by nature
of the certain population or demographic
that they fall into um so if we're
disagreeing on how that language can be
read then the rest of what I'm about to
say isn't really going to resonate but
um how that language is written and how
I read it and how I'm concerned someone
who might want to use this bill for
counterproductive or for harmful ends
could use that language um it does limit
topics of unconscious bias again and I'm
not talking about in the classroom I
understand that that's not where this
bill is aimed but it does limit those
topics coming up in example in spaces
like teacher trainings and I know as
people have said repeatedly this bill
doesn't limit diversity and inclusion
trainings and maybe it wasn't meant to
but this language could be used to
accomplish that um and the concern there
is that there are two steps here right
there's teachers teaching students and
the conversations that's happening in
the classroom but then there's what's
happening before teachers get in the
classroom and how equipped they are to
understand the nuances of different
lived experiences as many of the testif
finds have talked about today um and how
to engage with those constructively in a
classroom so that we are having a
productive and nuanced dialogue and not
just you know hurdling insults across
the aisle and unless teachers are
trained on how to really tease out the
the fundamental differences in those
conversations in a way that's productive
and also not harmful or not biased and
not uh in any way pervasively negative
to certain populations of its
students those conversations aren't
going to happen in a way that's actually
helpful so they're going to happen and
they're going to happen for these
students for the rest of their lives
just by nature of growing up in today's
America but if we want the students to
be able to do that well we need teachers
to be able to do that well and teachers
can't be taught how to do that well if
they can't be informed that we are human
and therefore we have biases we see the
World by nature of our experience and
those experiences are different and they
need to be able to be talked about and
teased out again in hopefully
professional productive settings uh so
that they can better teach students
thank you very much thank you
question uh yeah I was just gonna ask I
was wondering if it was possible that
the reason why uh women are more likely
to die in fire accidents is because they
actually have physically weaker bodies
and not necessarily a bias on the
engineers design the car I think that's
aant to this bill I'm afraid so I'm
going to squel the question we could
speculate on that for hours and I'd be
glad to some other time I was gonna say
if you want to email me we can have that
discussion there are answers to your
question but yeah I don't know that it
pertains directly to the language of the
you okay uh L Spen excuse me that
representative Shu has a question you
too you do too okay thank you Madam
chair um I don't actually have a
question for this person but I just
wanted to call to the chair's attention
that Mr padmore from the medical society
I believe had signed to speak and has
not been called has to leave the meeting
at 3:30 I was wondering if you might be
able
TOs and Pon you had a question I do um
you you
just she's not on the screen but ma'am
you just said something
brilliant you said we see the World by
the nature of our experiences and I
would completely agree with you but the
problem
with that's going on here that's being
addressed is that that is not what this
bill is covering does this bill not say
that you see the world based on your
gender or your sex how you were born and
experience I'm sorry sir I don't know
that I understand exactly what you're
trying to get at with your question I
would say that those two are
interrelated um so I'm not I'm not I
think that might be those things are
mutually inclusive so I'm not really
sure how you're trying to distinguish
them thank
you Mr
padmore thank you for your testimony
thank you very much good afternoon can
everyone hear me yes well good afternoon
Madam chair and members of the committee
for the record my name is Michael hadm
more director of advocacy for the New
Hampshire Medical Society representing
physicians in the granite state the New
Hampshire Medical Society along with the
American Medical Association the New
Hampshire Psychiatric Society the New
Hampshire American Academy of Pediatrics
the New Hampshire American College of
Physicians uh and the New Hampshire
Academy of family physicians strongly
oppose HB 544 um from a public health
standpoint there is clear evidence that
inequities and disparities
disproportionately affect people of
color and women we need to learn about
these topics and trainings in order to
address them and create true Health
Equity in New Hampshire if we can't talk
about the facts we can't solve the
problem uh there is extensive there is
an extensive body of evidence in medical
literature and Broad Acceptance in the
medical community that racism and sexism
have negatively impacted health and the
well-being of people of color and women
throughout history of this country in
fact many of the country's medical
associations have recognized racism is a
Public Health crisis covid has shown us
irrefutable differences in health
outcomes between race and sex categories
in New Hampshire this is further
described in the governor's covid-19
Equity Response Team initial report and
recommendations uh we must be able to
understand and address these differences
known as health disparities training
Physicians and other healthc care
providers to understand the impacts of
racism and sexism on the on health is
imperative to the ability to care for
patients and improve health outcomes
additionally as Physicians we cannot be
limited in our ability to treat diseases
not being able to train doctors on
racism and sexism and its effects on
health outcomes is tantamount to saying
doctors can't learn about treating covid
or cancer as physician scientists we
must practice evidence-based medicine to
best care for our patients rather than
serving as divisive Concepts regular
training on racism and sexism in
medicine is integral to understanding
how to improve the health and well-being
of all graned stators Health disparities
impact the economy as well this is
evidenced by this month's business New
Hampshire magazine cover story
highlighting racial inequity in
healthcare um the reporter actually
reached out to me uh the New Hampshire
Medical Society to begin her
investigation uh reflecting the
recognition that understanding these
Concepts uh is important for the
business sector additionally a healthy
Workforce is necessary for a vibrant
economy an American Hospital Association
brief states that Health disparities
amount to approximately 93 billion
dollar in excess medical care costs and
$42 billion in loss productivity per
year and describes the violent or excuse
me the vital uh connection between
Health Equity and value as improvements
in Health Equity can provide tremendous
value to patients hospitals and the
healthc care delivery system while we
wholeheartedly concur with a statement
in h 544 that no one should be judged by
their Color Race ethnicity sex or any
other characteristic protected by
federal or state law it is also crucial
to acknowledge that prohibiting these
things uh would Rob Physicians of the
their ability to inform and treat their
patients it is Our obligation to
practice medicine with impartiality
regardless of our patients gender Andor
background in order to do so research
has demonstrated that regular training
or unconscious bias positively impacts
patient uh excuse me physician patient
interactions and patient experiences
within the health system furthermore if
we don't fully understand the social
determinance of health and how the
structural determinance of racism and
sexism impact Health we cannot fully
inform our patients in their medical
decision-making censorship of our
ability to accurately teach assess and
treat patients is against our hypocritic
oath this applies especially for
state-funded health entities including
federally qualified Health Centers
Community Mental Health Centers and the
New Hampshire hospital which serve dis
excuse me which serve a disproportionate
number of people of color and women in
our state the medical profession in the
granded state acknowledges and supports
a patient's right to make their own
decisions that are fully informed
regardless of the physician's personal
beliefs we strongly oppose anything that
would censor Physicians freedom of
speech for patients to make informed
decisions we further affirm that the
government should not interfere in the
doctor patient relationship thus there
is no place for government to legislate
trainings that impact uh Physicians
ability to care for people understanding
the impacts of racism and sexism on
health is fundamental to our practice of
medicine and Public Health in New
Hampshire regular trainings help improve
clinical and Public Health outcomes in
both the private and public sectors they
help promote a free and fair economy and
they excuse me and they help Physicians
support individuals in making better
better informed Health decisions finally
they help to ensure that the government
and health and Health Care organizations
work for everyone because we are all
fair and excuse me because we all fair
better when we are all well thank you
pass I just have one last paragraph
passage of this legislation would
jeopardize the significant progress we
have made in the granted state in
considering and understanding Health
disparities that are directly
attributable to racial and gender
inequities it would therefore undermine
Public Health initiatives and make it
more difficult to improve the health of
all citizens in this great state we
strongly urge the committee to vote itl
on hp44 and I thank you for your
time will you answer some questions I
will thank you representative Roy thank
greater representative I'm having a real
real hard time hearing
you yeah is that better I can hear you
fine thank you okay thank you um in your
testimony you indicated that the due to
racial um
disparities that there are greater
negative outcomes and deaths
that you attributed to to racism and it
might be um this bill would would
infringe on a doctor's right to discuss
that with their patients I believe um
one of the leading causes of death in
the United States is medical error I was
wondering is is that any of that due to
racism or is it just other
[Music]
deaths I don't I don't know if I can
answer that question representative but
I appreciate your question thank
you
thank you representative Schmidt you had
a
[Music]
up thank
you
being
[Music]
understand we can't hear you at Peter
we're going to we're going to go on if
you don't
mind we can't understand the word you're
saying could you provide a cop you
Peter now we can hear you please
speak I'm not moving I don't know what
provide okay one a written copy of Mr P
pad I believe the question was can I
provide uh written testimony yes I have
sent this actually before the original
hearing for this I did send uh a copy of
that
Doctor
Spencer hello Madam chair thank you for
taking my testimony today and thank you
to all the committee members here um my
name is Louise Spencer I'm from
conquered New Hampshire I am co-founder
of the Kent Street Coalition which is an
all volunteer Grassroots advocacy
organization but I am here today
speaking on my own behalf um and I am
here to speak opposed to HB
544 um I just want to note I know that
attorney Binet talked about the um that
Trump the president's EO number 13 was
um enjoyed Nationwide in part because of
free speech concerns but also the judge
found that the EO was so vague that it
was impossible for plaintiffs to
determine which conduct would be
prohibited so this bill if adopted into
law would invite lawsuits and therefore
is fiscally irresponsible in my opinion
um on its merits um I would say that
often to understand why we may not
perceive something as racist as
anti-semitic as sexist Etc it is
necessary to deeply examine our own
lives and the biases that arise from our
lived experience we often need to be
challenged to do this because it is
inherently difficult and uncomfortable
to do the need for this kind of
examination can be seen right here in
this legislative body the fact that we
could have two cting members of the
House claim ignorance as a defense after
posting overtly anti-semitic and racist
memes on their social media accounts
shows just please do not talk
about do not attack other members or
other people please just concentrate on
the bill and what your testimony is
madam chair I would like to challenge
that ruling because I feel that any
example of racism and sexism per that um
perpetuates the very same bias that is
being challenged by this bill is
absolutely
germine it's an attack on the specific
ref it's not it's no simply stating a
fact about what people have tweeted or
said publicly in social media is
absolutely Germain shut down when they
were referencing her tweets thank you
proceed you need to unmute yourself
sorry thank
you my point is that too it's too easy
to claim ignorance about
things that are deeply racist deeply
anti-semitic deeply offensive um if we
do not do the sorts of training and
education that we need to do we should
never allow um ignorance to be an
excuse and um
particularly when certain material can
be demonstrably proven to be um hostile
toward another person based on their
race based on their sex based on their
religion so it's
imperative that this sort of training be
allowed and I think it's something that
we need to take a look at here in New
Hampshire right in our own
backyard
um and the fact that someone can
claiming ignorance but then that can be
used as a valid defense is even more
troubling so in my opinion there are no
amendments that could make this a good
bill um because in any form it would
chill the free exchange of ideas in
violation of the First Amendment and
important Civic
discourse racism sexism islamophobia
anti-Semitism ableism homophobia Etc are
the actual divisive
Concepts unfortunately we can't ban
these apparent Concepts but we can
educate ourselves and others so that we
no longer deny their existence thank you
very
much thank you very
much um I'm happy to take questions if
there are
any I don't see any
except for representative Schultz you
may have a brief
question so I don't know that I heard
the point Miss Spencer you were trying
to make about the social media posts
that you were referencing earlier
representative
Schultz thank
relevant okay I can submit in writing um
the the material that I I think is
relevant to this
discussion that would be very helpful
yes I won't continue it here thank you
very
much
uh there is a person listed as State Rep
Maria
Perez so are you here I which which
state are you
from
that that's New Hampshire yeah Madam
chair she's a a new rep from
Milford good well I've tried call
promoting her about six times and she
representative
Perez there you are
yes please unmute yourself and uh speak
to us
please thank you for the opportunity to
speak against this
bill um I'm a state representative Maria
Perez um new representative for v623 in
Milford we have enough racism as it is
right now we don't need another bill
that is going to give people the
right to raise to treat people
differently because the skin color
because the language or because what
whatever they're from and I believe this
country was
built by immigrants
if you're not a Indian like Native
American you're not like real American
we have to teach our kids we have so
many backgrounds we have so many
different cultures that I believe our
kids benefit from learning all these
different backgrounds and cultures and
then we need to teach our kids how to
respect women how to respect people no
matter where you're from no matter what
you look how you look or where you from
or what language do you speak I believe
this bill is like totally needs to like
we can't we can't let this bill
pass as an immigrant as a personal color
I see already discrimination against me
in the
workplace when I go out people think
that it's right to tell me that I don't
belong to this country because I didn't
born in here because I have an accent or
because my skin color
we have enough discrimination as it is
why why do we need another bill to give
the people a right to keep discriminate
against people different cultures and
and and why we don't let the teachers
teach the kids that we all different and
we all we all have different backgrounds
our kids they need to learn that because
a lot of our kids they go to different
countries and they for example they get
jobs in like like different continents
and they has to learn
the culture before they can like be able
to do the job correctly so I believe the
kids have benefit from learning
different cultures when they're in
school my kids is like they they they
have a different different background
they speak two different languages and
the benefits they get from learning
different cultures and not only they
they they know Spanish my daughter know
French and they they learn like
different cultures from different other
uh areas in the world and that's a big
benefit when you know a lot of different
cultures when you're trying to get a a a
better
job thank you representative Perez will
you take a
question no I will not take questions
thank you thank you H thank you for your
Hills
about six
times six
times there he is David Hills
yes
welcome Mr
Hills
unmuted there he is okay yes you have to
Hills my name's David and if you're
referring to me no you're next there's
someone named David H that is I've been
trying to call for a
while I'm very sorry about that can you
hear me now yes there you are and excuse
me because I'm in a bit of a
construction zone here but uh Madame
chairwoman uh and committee members my
name is David Hills I live in Durham and
I'd like to thank you all first of all
for your service uh as an introduction
I'm 66 I'm the father of five and I'm
the 10th Generation on the oldest family
farm in our country uh my ancestors also
donated the land to what is now
University of New Hampshire uh
professionally I was in the investment
business uh for 34 years becoming re
before uh retiring and becoming uh
irrelevant three years ago um I'm an
independent voter and was happy to vote
for Warren Redman it's a bit of my
background I think it's important to
know uh who speaking regarding House
Bill 544 I am opposed to this bill in
the spirit of brevity I'll just say that
the bill is written seems as though it
would enable the state of New Hampshire
in any way to dictate what classes are
offered and what is
discussed uh to students and uh being an
elder person who would like to uh always
be educated to me I don't believe the
state of New Hampshire should be telling
me or anyone what classes can or can uh
be taken and what can be
offered uh it also seems to me as
previous speakers have said to be an
issue of uh First Amendment rights being
trampled on uh this bill also seems to
go against the free marketplace with in
regard to uh uh uh opportunities for
Education H in the University system and
what by that what I mean is that if no
one is interested in having these
conversations around the uh topics that
were're disc discussing today then
people will not attend and if people are
interested in learning and having
conversations they will I don't
understand um the fear that it it seems
uh some people are experiencing my
ancestors left England in 1660 as best
uh I've been able to figure out to
escape oppression and experience the
Free World I don't want the state of New
Hampshire telling me as I said what I
can learn about um I also uh maybe the
10th Generation a family farm but I'm
also recognizing that there were many
generations before my family who lived
on this same land and I think it's
important for me to learn and grow and
understand uh how these people were
oppressed and how these and the plight
of these people and I'm Not Afraid about
learning about that and I'm afraid I'm
not afraid to admit that uh uh this
oppression existed personally I've
learned a lot in the last few years on
many issues um I've learned that racism
in a more deeply way I've known racism
exists but I've learned in a more deeply
way that it exists uh in our country and
about my own personal privilege uh as a
person whose skin by birth is white um I
look forward to learning more about this
and again I'm not afraid to do so uh it
may be worth noting that uh the FBI
recently determined that the greatest uh
threat to National Security is domestic
white nationalist groups
um I think that um that may be a stretch
for the conversation of today but I
think it's background material is really
important for us to uh understand that
being open to this conversation um and
uh and issues like this are really
important for our country to come
together I don't think again it's the
state of New Hampshire's job to in any
way legislate uh what professors or
teachers uh can uh speak to and I
respectfully uh request that the
committee uh vote against House Bill 544
thank you thank you Mr
Davidson Madame chairman can you hear me
yes Mr Davidson please thank you and to
all the committee here uh I sent out a
list of PowerPoint slides which I
understand are in possession so can we
confirm that you have them and I'll
speak to them uh in short order
no no Mr Davidson I'm not going to
present your slides we have them we will
we will view them and read them we want
you to speak to
us very good if you can follow along
that would be great so my my first my
first thought uh is just my background
is I'm a former public high school
teacher I used to teach American
government and afro Asian cultural
studies
uh I'm a former ranking member of the
House Brookline Cooperative School
District budget committee I'm a
multi-generational uh uh member of a
mixed race family uh my children are
also part of abanaki and Cherokee and uh
I've received uh Public Service Awards
in over two States including JC's and
from the town of Hollis so uh my first
slide was any discrimination versus
critical race Theory and I I rise in
support of HB
544 uh discrimination is discrimination
and a theory is an unproven thought and
those are the takeaways I want you to
have for uh for anti-discrimination and
critical race Theory so are we there yet
well I have friends who were Freedom
Writers in Mississippi back in the 1960s
and they were held hostage by the Jim
Crow types for several days before they
were released and I remember my father's
best friend's family when we were
sitting Vig
from Father Jim feny who was held
hostage when Robert Kennedy from the
White House as the Attorney General
called our friend's house and said that
our friend had been released so if the
60s was about anything it was about what
Martin Luther King said I dream of a day
when my four children will not be judged
by the color of their skin but by the
content of their character that is
really the essence of what I think
antidiscrimination and critical race
theory is all about now are we there yet
well who maybe I'm not the best to say
but ask alv King Dr Ben Carson Michael
Jordan financier Charles Pay Candace
Owens actor Morgan Freeman and justi as
Claris thommen if we're here that
virtually all of them came from Humble
means and Rose to what they Rose to I
don't have to tell you so uh I want to
keep in mind that that to me is the
essence and The Benchmark of what we
should be doing the I Have a Dream
statement of Dr
King uh here in Hollis we have a Dei
committee diversity equity and inclusion
committee and basically the message is
to get woke and have it attended some of
the the meetings and spoken to some of
those who were members it's clear to me
that empirical data is being replaced by
Theory and repace replaced by consensus
building uh that's one of the real
drawbacks of uh the critical race theory
is that they pit Equity versus equality
Equity being equal outcome and equality
basically being equal opportunity in
fact the committee that's here in Hollis
it's actually with the co-op Hollis
Brookline SAU 41 actually is redefining
Equity to mean equal opportunity so you
know words mean things as they're
written in the dictionary whether you go
to Wikipedia or whether you go to
britanica or you go to Webster and
Equity means equal outcome equality of
opportunity means just that so there's a
a a clear deconomy between outcome
versus opportunity and and they used and
I'll use the analogy of running a race
if it's 100 meter race you all start at
the at the start line the shot goes off
people run down the 100 meters then they
finish first second or third or whatever
but in an equity world everybody
finishes at the same
time and they use the term building
Equity Building Equity is critical race
Theory and it's it's it's not a it's not
an effort of discover y it's an effort
of
advocacy now moving
forward when you invoke the strategies
of the diverse inequity inclusion
committees and critical race Theory you
basically look at everything through a
prism of racism so all of society is
viewed for that prism of racism personal
and group identity is viewed that way
and the groups are defined as as as the
dominant versus the subordinate so you
have the oppressors and you have the
victims
and again looking through that prism all
of our laws institutions and history are
inherently racist the further these
inequalities must be corrected through
equity and that's the distribution of
wealth and resources and in that the
Norms of our society changed our society
no longer is a
meritocracy in that prism of racism view
public and private bonds are weakened
and education is not one of Discovery as
in a atic method but indeed
indoctrination and one of the remarks
mentioned by some of the earlier
speakers haven't worked Beyond teaching
in it and contract law I'm not an
attorney but I I've worked in them there
are several opportunities to show where
there's equal opportunity in in in the
in the companies and agencies that might
do business with the state and that's
done today through eeo so there's many
proven models to do that so when you
look at uh when you look at the critical
race further white people Foster
differences that create have created
this inequality and they're they're
they're the
boogeyman they're their inequalities are
systemic and they're ones of subjugation
and they create poverty and I said to
the the the sa and the co-op here in
Hollis Brookline if indeed we have
systemic racism in in this town or for
that matter in this state then where are
the incident reports that have been
filed through the schools where are the
police reports where have the people
been using the rsas to correct these
inadequacies because clearly they would
be if they had been occurring and if
they've been systemic and if there is
not this data then then you have to
intellectually reject this because these
events have not been filed and actions
have not been taken in a legal manner
which there are many Provisions for and
that we would encourage them to do if
indeed they were
real uh the end game is to normalize
this whole methodology of advocacy and
and pushing theories and uh you know
when you look at having studied Mao and
the red guards the olinsky strategies
blem and Tifa which
are groups well BLM is a corporation
which actually is trying to destroy the
nuclear family their strategies are
dividing conquer they're about
reparations and they're about
unlearning so uh I have some slides
please take a look at them then show one
of the questions that came out before
critical a race theory is actively being
taught there was a uh recently a uh a
school district the Meer Hol School
District in copertino San Jose where
they advocated power and privilege being
identified by whether and this is third
graders are you white are you middle
class are you cisgender are you
cisgender male are you educated are you
able-bodied those are all identities
that hold power and privilege of one
over the other and that was in the
curriculum likewise in Hollis I included
a summary of a letter that our uh
petition group here in Hollis to get to
stop critical race Theory took notes
going as far back as October
2020 where they talked about white
people being the subjugators and I quote
white people are the only ones who can
white
people treat people very badly because
they have power they cause racism they
created slavery they brought it to this
country and this is directly from a
letter from aah Hollis grade two and
three parent because this transcended
the year of a a parent in Hollis and I
can send you the letter with the
permission of the author with their name
and uh and their his wife's name
redacted and as ask him to uh speak to
the committee in private because he's a
he's afraid of repercussions against his
family and against his child so in
summary the prism of Iden the prism of
identity politics and race I ask you
intellectually will it nurture and teach
and Foster self-confidence of our
children and of our of our peer groups
whether professional or otherwise will
it bring us together will it forer
confidence in our community and I I
think the answer to those things is
clear as this is a divis of exercise at
its core and I also want to stress from
an educational standpoint as I also made
this presentation to sau41 will it
improve our math and reading scores here
we are in Hollis we still we we still
only have a 32% Proficiency in uh in
math um pardon me we have 32% of our
students who are not proficient in
mathematics at grade level in the high
school and 14 % are not proficient in
reading and I think part of this is an
obfuscation of responsibility from an
educational process standpoint because
it takes our Focus off the core
responsibility of basic skills in
education so again I ask you to vote
against discrimination okay I
discrimination is discrimination and I
ask you to choose to support
hb4 five 44 thank you thank you very
please Roy do you have a
question mistake one from Miss Schultz
no thank you it was a mistake someone
raise her hand by mistake Melissa B from
conquer oh Madam chair I did have a
question yes you can choose not to call
on me I guess but my question is you
mentioned that there a lot of school
systems Etc that you've raised this
issue with did you ask anyone that is a
person of color their view on this well
actually I didn't say that I raised it
up in many school systems I went through
Discovery and I I noted that the uh to
answer your question I think where
you're going with this the meero school
in copertino San Jose California is 70%
Asian and a large majority of those
individual parents 70
percentile uh are a foreign born and
they're immigrants to this country and
it was they that raised this up at the
meero school and uh where the advocate
who was against uh the critical race
Theory who is an Asian woman spoke very
strongly and in fact was on Fox News
speaking against the slides that I
forwarded to you that were used in the
curriculum okay so you ask no person of
color thank you well Madam chairman I
don't want words put into my mouth uh
there were actually uh people of color
on the on the diversity Equity inclusion
committee uh in Hollis Brookline that uh
I made my presentation to so that's not
correct and moreover I can speak to my
niece who is a mixed race police officer
in Virginia beats Virginia or any number
of other cousins and blood relatives if
that's important to you Miss
Schultz thank you Mr
Davidson thank
you Melissa B
I'm call good afternoon can you hear me
yes we can hear you good afternoon chair
Maguire and members of the New Hampshire
house Edna committee my name is Melissa
Bernardin I live in conquer and I've
resided in New Hampshire for most of my
life I signed up to speak on HB 544
today because it appears to me one of
the most backward thinking intolerant
pieces of legislation I've seen come
through this house and I've been
involved in public policy work in New
Hampshire for nearly two
decades I see words and phrases in this
legislation that smack of the sentiment
we've heard in recent months from people
who want to preserve the racist status
quo in this country like talking about
racism divides
us this line of thinking couldn't be
farther from the truth talking about
problems and weaknesses in the ways that
we think speak and act and then figure
out ways to better understand and
support each other will make our state
stronger and more united not more
divided most Americans believe that
America is about progress seeking
improvements and bettering ourselves
instead this bill would plug our ears
and close our eyes and ignore the
scourges of racism sexism ableism and
all the other horrid ableism that divide
us and rank some individuals Supreme
over others others it brings shame to
our state that legislation like this
which would curtail freedom of speech
freedom of study freedom of debate and
dialogue would even be suggested I urge
this committee to vote itl on HB
544 and in closing I would like to leave
the supporters of this bill with a
thought as white people we are not
harmed by being called
racist in contrast people who are not
white are harmed when we don't name
examine and work to deconstruct racism
in our society I have not yet sent in uh
written testimony but I would be happy
to I'll briefly make one more statement
the and and speaks to
testimony I I don't appreciate your
stating your opinions as facts quite
that firmly and I would hope that you
would be more respectful to those white
people in the
[Music]
audience many of whom are offended if
Ruba okay okay uh looks like I got video
can you folks hear me yes thank you okay
great thank you uh my name is Joe garuba
um I'm testifying today uh for myself
and for my two children who uh attend
school here in Hollis New Hampshire um I
wanted to start off with a couple of
observations and maybe a question before
I got to my um prepared comments uh I'll
be brief um first thing is I think
there's some confusion about the concept
of free speech in the framework of uh
public education so people most
certainly have the right of their free
speech right to claim that New Hampshire
is a systematically systemically racist
State that's that's their free speech
right but that's very different from the
right to take tax dollars and to have
those those Concepts taught to people's
children so when everybody's questioning
this bill and the content of this bill
in in the light of a a free speech
context it really has to be viewed from
the from the standpoint of we're talking
about teachers who are teaching children
impressionable children um Concepts that
are obviously quite controversial
because we wouldn't all be here with
hundreds of people on the line talking
about them if this was uh you know 2
plus 2 equals 4 so that was the first
thing I I just wanted to address I saw
as we were going through the testimony
the second thing is I've heard quite a
few folks mention that they have
submitted written testimony or will be
submitting written testimony and um it's
my understanding that those would be uh
government records and I wanted to know
if that would be available for uh folks
who are interested uh to review as well
as committee members yes they are still
being collected and I don't can't
guarantee that you could get them today
but the written testimony is submitted
it's in the bill file and it is a public
document as you stated great thank you
um I just have a brief uh comment on
critical race Theory and then I'll take
uh questions if anybody has any so
critical race Theory uh does not
distinguish between benevolent Authority
and oppression to critical race
theorists all authority is oppressive
and in essence you know the the New
Hampshire State House is a pressive
Authority and and it doesn't it doesn't
understand or the concept isn't the
differentiation between Authority used
in a positive way is not differentiated
and that's where you get all of these
all of these kind of distortions that
come out of out of applying this theory
in the real world so what what I would
ask the committee to do is specifically
to vote the HB 544 as ought to pass and
ensure that the state can continue to
improve on race relations instead of
having critical race Theory cause
divisions which is the outcome of the
implementation of that theory so if
anybody had any questions I'd be happy
them no I think you've made your point
very nicely thank you very much for your
testimony thank you ma'am sure yes one
of the people people who signed up to
testify Lily Williams says that she's
waiting but she has no video only audio
so I don't know if there's anybody in a
phone number I've asked her what number
she's calling from but haven't heard
that if she if you we could take video
we can take Audio Only testimony we need
to know who it is there's nobody with a
phone who's raised their
hand um that person raised their hand
raise their hand we're calling those all
right and and if it is a phone it's star
is I've got a phone number oh there you
are Grace K very good it's kand thank
you uh hello and thank you to the
committee for giving me the opportunity
to speak my name is Grace kand I am the
program coordinator with the American
friend service committee which is an
immigrant rights and racial Justice
organization I'm from Manchester and
have lived the majority of my life in
the granite state after immigrating here
as a toddler in 1989 as a black girl I
experienced schools that use my image to
show diversity on their brochures while
treating me like an alien as an an alien
other in the classroom as a black woman
I experienced employers purposely
underpaying me compared to other White
staff and threatening to fire me when I
confronted them these are just some
examples of the racism and that I in
that I directly experienced as a granite
Stater for the majority of the 33 years
that I've lived here I'm here in
opposition to HB 544 this is a bill
written from a place of fear about the
truth about the behaviors and choices of
our social systems in the impact that
those systems have had on past and
current generations of people our
discourse in decision- making is not
weakened by critical analysis that
challenges what we know pushes us to
understand more deeply and it enables us
to do better it is well documented and
well researched that racial gender
ableist and sexual inequities exist in
public policy and disproportionately
affect people of color disabled people
women and gender non-conforming folks
causing major disparities in the
economic health and educational outcomes
of these
communities it is embarrassing and
heartbreaking that our state continues
to debate whether or not racism sexism
and other isms exist while much of the
country including our neighbors our
regional neighbors like Maine are
getting on with the business of rooting
out oppression protecting against
discrimination and building smarter and
more inclusive societies it is crystal
clear that the purpose of this bill is
to muzzle the truth of who we are and
what we do in closing these concepts are
divisive divisive because of the harmful
impact that discriminatory violence
policies and choices have on those on
the receiving end of it they are not
divisive simply because those who have
and continue to hold social political
and economic power are uncomfortable and
are using that power to push through a
bill that will halt the trajectory of
truth I urge this community to vote itl
on HB 544 and I'm happy to take any
questions thank you very much uh
representative
Alro um I've never heard that the state
of the Hampshire denies the existence of
racism can you please uh provide me a
reference so that I can educate myself I
did just provide you a reference which
is my some of my direct experiences in
the schools and workplaces in the state
the state Deni the existence of of
racism and sexism right and as long as
as long as the state denies it then I
see that there is no need for a bill
like this which would make it impossible
for us to even speak of these things
you
madisonaz
Madison thank you Miss
kendi for your testimony kendi
you so can you hear me yes thank you oh
thank you I got kicked off and came back
thank you madam chair I appreciate the
time to speak um my name is Andrea nah
Diaz um I've reside in on Victoria
Street in Manchester I moved to New
Hampshire four years ago I'm an educator
and have been for 25 years um and I urge
that you oppose this
B44 um I just in in the spirit of
sharing personal experiences that people
aren't aware of and it's important for
everybody to be aware of um know as a
newcomer to the state I was delighted to
go to a um Workforce Development um
meeting when I first moved to New
Hampshire um and you know signed in on
the signin sheet like everybody else um
and was stunned find out that um uh
white supremacy groups um captured
images of the signin sheets and then I
was among many people who were put on a
on a white hating list on the website
with my photo aaph and my email and my
phone number for my workplace um it is
uh someone earlier said that that
incidents don't happen because people
don't report them and I can tell you
that incidents do happen and oftentimes
there's consequences for reporting them
and uh you know in my workplace I was
told that because it's free speech on
the internet um of course you know it
would only add Fu to the fire if I were
to challenge that but it's an example of
kind of I would say ignorance and and
maliciousness and targeting that takes
place and I just um my heart broke that
I know a lot of people um are working
against that kind of behavior but um
just sharing with you that that does
exist um in regarding this bill I think
there's been a kind of conflating of um
you
know there's a there's a debate on
critical race Theory and that will
continue and that's fine um this bill in
particular the it is it's a very
misleadingly crafted bill um the key
part in there about bias training there
is so much data and evidence on the
impact of some people call it
unconscious bias implicit bias
um basically if we're human beings and
we breathe air we have bias it's not
that we're bad people it's not any of
that it's that we socialized that we you
know we get socialized from all
different sources in society and we then
have bi so for example if I see two
white male gentlemen one's wearing a
denim jacket and one is wearing a suit
I'm asked to pick out which one probably
the banker and which one is the
carpenter cognitive bias is just how the
brain processes quickly it looks for
patterns and so I would then be seeing
you know I've been socialized that the
person with the suit on is the banker
when in fact it might not be the case
that's an example of bias it's not
something to be afraid of to learn about
it and this bill hamstrings people work
for uh an educational organization I
have 700 employees and we need to be
able
to make those trainings available to our
employees so that they can do a good job
in their work and helping them with
unconscious bias really all we're doing
is teaching people that it exists and
then people have the ability to mitigate
so that they can kind of catch
themselves when they might be realizing
that they're saying something with a
bias um so I just again I just want to
say that there there's this particular
ular bill as it is constructed does way
more harm than it than its um proponents
are talking about and we need to be very
very careful I urge you uh to vote down
against this bill and to make New
Hampshire a place where people can have
the conversations they need to and learn
together for a healthier
questions a question what C I think my
video was off during that I apologize so
please I'm happy to take questions
what's
CDO CDO stands for chief diversity
officer and I work for a small College
where I do that work and I did want to
just make a slight correction for
someone who said that Equity is the same
as equal opportunity it's not Equity is
giving someone with dyslexia more time
to take the test math
test quality is giving everybody the
same thing 50 minutes to take your math
test Equity is giving someone who has
giving people what they need so they can
have equ opportunity it's not about
guaranteeing outcomes it's about
removing barriers so they have equal
opportuni so if I have a student who's
got dyslexia and that's documented in
their you know in their um
individualized uh forms then we give
them more time to take their exam so we
can actually measure their performance
on math not whether they cognate really
fast on numbers so I just wanted to
clarify that yes that's the role thank
you very much and Madam chair Willie
Williams is having technical problem she
should be on with her hand raised
okay we're we're moving people up this
Madison um hi thank you so much for
calling me um so my name is Madison
Howard um I live uh here in Conquer New
Hampshire about a mile away from the
state house actually um I am a senior at
conquered high school and I would like
to speak today in strong opposition to
HP 544 I'd like to start by saying that
I have lived in New Hampshire for
practically my entire life and I love
living here but growing up as a
korean-american in the third whitest
state in the country has come with its
challenges I've routinely faced racial
harassment I've been called names and
slurs that I won't repeat in front of
the committee today um and I bring this
up because if you ask any person of
color if they have similar experiences I
guarantee they will say yes and this is
because racist behaviors um are so
common because they are weaved into the
fabric of our country let us not forget
that our country was built on the labor
of enslaved black Americans who far too
many white Americans justified enslaving
by asserting they were subhuman in 1833
Andrew Jackson the Man still on our $20
bills said of indigenous Americans as
justification for his Mass extermination
of them they have neither the
intelligence the industry the moral
habits nor the desire of improvement
which are necessary to any favorable
change in their condition during World
War II Frank President Franklin D
Roosevelt put 120,000 and Japanese
Americans in internment camps and
Justified this by calling them quote
dangerous and undesirable unquote this
is the reality of our country's history
and it is vital that we recognize how
our country's past has created racial
disparities in the present as Dr Bennett
and Miss Carpenter said as well as many
other testified we can see these racial
disparities this evidence of the
continued existence of systemic racism
we see this in the job market and
housing education in medicine and in
public
accommodation I myself am proud to be a
member of my school district's racial
Equity Advisory Group where we work to
combat these disparities in our school
system we have made an immense amount of
progress and I feel so proud to be part
of a community that prioritizes
anti-racism HP 544 however would
prohibit this group as well as any other
discussion within our schools
surrounding the reality of our country's
past the sponsor of the bill himself
said last week that this bill is meant
to Target diversity trainers HB 544
wants to censor Educators across the
state and force them to lie to students
to erase the true history of our country
in order to make white people feel more
comfortable but by doing this we will
never be able to address the pervasive
racism people of color like me face
today thank you and please vote um itl
544 um representative Schultz you have a
question
thank you Mr chair I just want to take a
moment uh if you'll allow a little
latitude as a conquered rep and she is a
child to thank her for her testimony and
to tell you that I'm proud of you um and
I'm appreciate that you were willing to
step in this controversial topic and
you've done so with great strength and
Grace thank you thank
you you're welcome and I would second
that by saying that we're all proud of
young people embracing the political
process um any other questions please
for the
witness none uh thank you for your
testimony have a great day I am now
going to recognize um all I see is Lily
on the screen I'm gonna sure your proper
ma' okay go ahead can you hear me can
you can hear me well okay go ahead yeah
well thank you chair thank you committee
members my name is Lily Tong Williams
and I live in where New Hampshire and I
represent myself as a former Chinese
immigrant from a People's Republic of
China I was born and grown in China
before I came to this country I was a
assistant law school professor in
Shanghai I decid to FL CH and FL China
for America not go to Europe because I
truly believed our fing fathers document
the Declaration of
Independence all men are cre equal I
first landed in Austin Texas when I was
about 24 years old without speaking much
English and I live in a white
neighborhood 98% white and I went to
graduate school in UT Austin also most
white and I can tell you about my
personal experience everybody was so
nice and welcoming they help me to adapt
to a new country and they offer me the
free right to go to grocery stores
because I was very poor I only borrowed
$100 to come to this country and they
donated clothing cooking stuff household
items to me include blankets and sheets
say
my English was very poor my classmates
were very nice to me and offer me to um
borrow their notes and help me with
school project I also met my future
husband the first night in Austin Texas
and later we married after d it for two
years his entire family members were
right they open welcome me and with the
warmth and with trust actually they just
loved me
and I feel so blessed of course to have
a a family in America because I come
here Al I did not have anybody any
family and friends were close to me and
so I be honest with you we rais three
Rich children mixed race children and uh
I lived in America now for total of uh
um 88 so 32 years I have never
experienced that this discrimination due
to my skin color or my race except one
incident it was a road rage insult
comment and from a lady of course I
stood up for myself and she was gone and
uh I'm leaving American Dream today
consider my humble past from a totalitar
country and I love this country I
strongly reject critical race Theory I'm
here to support bill because this
critical race theory is infecting our
country now for years I learned about
history of American slavery I also
learned history about discrimination
against Chinese Americans Japanese
Americans and uh I loved Dr King whose
famous speech I Have a
Dream and since the Civil Rights
Movement America has come a long way
I remember that so many actually and
people of the color today got a elected
into government
offices and own homes have a businesses
and uh I have lots of friends also from
all walks of life I do not agree America
is a systemic racist country otherwise
why would the meons minons Immigrant
want to come to this country and have
come to this country from all over the
world to better their lives they wanted
to come here to achieve American Dream
critical three theory is based on skin
color and race pure and simple it creat
hatred it creates division that our
country really don't need right now I
think it's the tool to be used by the
radical left to divide and conquer I
grew up during the rain of ma the
dictator you should all know right I
hope so and uh experience his entire 10
years cultural revolution with my own
eyes I was a little child let me tell
you this racist
theory is a technic similar to what
happen to US during Mouse regime it
separate citizens into two big giant
groups victims who are oppressed and and
oppressors are the white people
especially white males that I happened
to married to one and the namei also
expressed I was terrified because I
remember ma used getting rid of whole
like destroy the four old campaign to
basically to use the young red guards to
achieve absolute power he become a god
during the cultural revolution
controlled his regime controlled 1.3
billion human lives and he divided a
citizen into 10 classes five red like me
red child from a workers's class and the
five blacks you can easily find out what
they are I don't want to get into
specific those t classes here but he
urged the red guards those people who
worship Him who were young I leave and
who did not know the history to publicly
shame and the black classes people have
to come out to cutto to basically belong
themselves soall their Blackness instead
of whiteness and they also beat them up
if they don't do criticize
correctly when when I saw what happened
last summer in our country months and
months of riots and and nuding and the
public shaming people if you don't join
the New Movement some people might
support the black life movement
[Music]
but um stop for a second please um could
you please wrap it up um I want to keep
everyone's testimony equal and you've
had quite amount of
time fascinating could listen to it all
day but I want to be
fair
thank you so I wanted to just testify
that I witnessed 10 years cultural
revolution I don't really want that
happen to our country because America is
a home we have no place to go if we know
the American as a free country we can
deal with individual cases of racism and
the police brutality but we have so much
in common as American citizens we love
this country we want have the best for
our kids and our future so please
support this bill and this bill is um
going to I think not silence the another
side we can still have discussions and
and conversations but you don't use
taxpayers money to support critical
theory thank you very much thank you
very much for your testimony
Schultz thank you I um believe your
husband is a State
Rep oh no no okay sorry someone no we
are new here we just moved here from
Colorado oh welcome to New Hampshire
sorry one year ago thank you not a
relevant question I apologize that's all
right I do welcome your question
sir any other questions thank
you yeah um okay uh Miss Clark please
you have to unmute
[Music]
yourself hello my name is Gabrielle
Clark and
um I have been exposed to critical race
theory in my family and um I'll tell you
about what happened with my
son my son um was his name is William
Martin Clark his middle name is Martin
because he was born on Martin Luther
King day of that year and earlier this
year he was asked to complete a project
in his class where he had to list his I
his
identities his uh racial identity his uh
his religion his sexual identity all of
those things and because he
refused he was retaliated against
he suffered some
serious um emotional distress as have I
because he refused to be categorized as
an oppressor since he is a straight
white
male since he is a straight white male
they have decided for him that he's an
oppressor and he is uh privileged when
this
boy his father died when he was one
years
old when this all happened we were
living in a motel and William was
sleeping on a mat on the floor there's
nothing privileged about my son's life
and just because he's the straight white
male doesn't give anybody the right to
make that decision and that distinction
and that determination that is what
critical race Theory does and if you if
you don't root this out right now you
will be suffering this same thing in
your schools in your jobs and everywhere
else it is a poison and you need to get
rid of it you can teach Racial equality
and you can even you can
even decide that racial Equity is is
something that you want to uh pursue
without critical race Theory as the
basis for doing it you want Racial
equality you want racial Equity teach
the kids math teach the kids English
make sure they get good jobs and they
have the have the skills to move forward
in life you do not need this nonsense it
is corrosive it is disgusting you should
get rid of it and I am a person of color
and I am saying
this all my life I have been able to
make my own decision and take care of my
own self and whenever I needed to I got
got help because this is America and if
you need help you get help if you're
being discriminated against you file a
complaint or you file a lawsuit or you
do something about you do not need other
people to tell you how you should or
should not think or what you should or
should not
do that is what critical race Theory
does and it is
gross thank you thank you very much Miss
Clark appreciate your testimony could
question
broa thank you madam chair thank you for
testifying Miss Clark can you please
tell me what school um you son attends
you you can see all of that information
at Schoolhouse rights.org because we
filed our lawsuit
there
mad chair I think the answer to that
question is Las Vegas
Nevada thank you representative
sh uh Jonathan Weinberg
please hi uh thank you for this
opportunity my name is Jonathan Weinberg
and I'm a recently elected member of the
conquered school board however I'm
speaking in my capacity as an individual
and not on behalf of the board I'm here
in strong opposition to the bill if it
is truly about protection creating unity
and not promoting virence then it would
include any mention of gender maybe
everyone's saying their pronouns Min are
he him his by the way as a blueprint uh
furthermore section four if we can look
at that under the race or sex
scapegoating it plainly ignores science
it classifies any claim that consciously
or unconsciously and by virtue of his or
her race or sex members of any race are
inherently racist it labels that as a
divisive concept AKA it is attempting to
prevent implicit bias training lastly to
discuss critical race theory for a
second I debated in college and so you
need to actually understand the
fundamentals of critical race Theory
including afro pessimism and afro
futurism not just look at a Fox News
article or two we need to learn about
complete histories and not merely from a
single lens perhaps explore Chim Chanda
Neo indi's dangers of a single story as
well so I'd recommend the committee
actually study up on what the
representative proposing this bill is
using as their fuel additionally as a
previous opponent of this proponent of
this bill group these together blatantly
racist and
anti-American topics so logically if
you're racist and anti-American then it
is obviously necessary to be anti-racist
and American which in itself requires
intellectually stimulating conversations
with a robust emphasis on how races has
manifested throughout the years from the
trans Atlantic slave trade to Jim Crow
to mass incarceration let's be
anti-racist together and astoundingly
vote down this Bill thank
much okay uh Leila you have your name
your hand
up can you hear me yes okay um I just
like to say thank you um for having me
here I'm just gonna I'm not going to
read all of my written testimony I'm
just going to skim through it um some of
the stuff has already been talked about
by other people and they've made a
better point of it than I have first off
i' just like to say I am a lifelong
liberal I am a classical liberal I care
about civil rights um but I really don't
feel that critical race theory is the
best way to solve our problems of racism
I think there are better ways um to do
it that that don't include programs that
are so divisive um so here I will start
and read here I am here in support of
hp55 my teenage daughter lives in
Sandown New Hampshire with her father
and step family she is a resident of New
Hampshire or she has been a resident of
New Hampshire and a student of the New
Hampshire public schools for about four
years um as a parent I am concerned
about the possibility of critical race
Theory being taught in schools and I'd
also like to add um that her father and
her stepmother are also in agreement
with me um so I am speaking for all of
us um he wanted to be here today but he
has work and stuff um anyways
um for many years critical race Theory
made sense to me um sometimes I would
even get into arguments with friends
about it I I many many years I believed
in it um it wasn't until it became more
popular and more talked about that I
could see how it was divisive and also
unscientific um it doesn't allow for any
other any other school of thought in um
so now I feel that critical race Theory
does more harm than good um and in
recent years it has become highly
controversial
if we bring critical race Theory into
our schools and workplaces I feel it
will bring on more tensions and div
divisions between people I would like to
show some examples of how critical race
theory has been poorly received in other
parts um of the country as reported in
three articles I found online in a
December 220 article from Christian
today entitled Southern Baptist keep
quarreling over critical race Theory
there is discussion about how some
Southern Baptists feel that critical
race theory is incomp comptible with
their face and disagreements have risen
about this in their Community I'll just
skip to the end of the quote and say
this is this was a quote by Albert Moher
president of the Southern Baptist
Theological Seminary and he stated we
stand together and stating that we
believe that advocating critical race
Theory or intersectionality is
incompatible with the Baptist faith and
message and that at that such advocacy
has no rightful place within the SBC
Seminary I think it speaks loudly to
Southern Baptist that we take this stand
together end quote now my take on this
is that not every church is is going to
is going to feel this way um but some of
them well and and and and if if churches
feel this way and some some religious
groups feel this way it's going to cause
conflict within those churches and
within families um the next article that
I'd like to talk about um to show an
example of how it didn't go well in
another place is um the an article from
the college fixed and
activist organized to expel critical
race Theory from California's ethnic
studies model
curriculum um the article talks about
how various groups um including Jewish
groups and Arab Arab groups um spoke out
against um the California's ethnic
studies model curriculum um and even
after they did revisions they were still
not happy and
then I'm going to quote uh the
representative from the alliance for
constructive ethnic studies told the
college um fix her name is Lisa renson
she said that the group was formed in
2019 because of concerns the first trp
of the curriculum was incredibly
anti-semitic and
anti-American um later in the same
article an educator Lori Myers stated by
teaching that people are divided into
either oppressors or oppressed groups
based solely on their skin color and
that white people have all the power and
non-white people have none of the power
critical race theory is a device of
classroom environment that Fosters
resentment and Bully bullying between
students of different races end
quote um the last article I'm just going
to skip because it's already been
referenced by a few other people that
spoke um but it was about that that
school in
California
um
and in closing I would like to say that
I have personally seen people lose
people um over political disagreements
on the past four years I have seen more
than a few friendships the dissolve and
families divided over politics um one of
my friends just moved she just took her
newborn baby and moved out of New
Hampshire because she couldn't agree
with her family anymore over politics um
so it's this is this is something that
I've seen personally and this is
something that I have never ever seen in
my lifetime I have never seen people
this divided um critical race Theory um
divides people at some point it may end
up in my daughter's school or future
workplace and I don't want her exposed
to things that go against unity and that
may put at odds with her classmates
friends Andor family and I don't want to
see my fellow Americans become more
divided by
politics um I'm including in my written
statement um a few more articles um
about about critical race Theory and I I
encourage everybody to read these
articles and the ones that I quoted and
um I just like to say thank you for
giving me the opportunity to speak um
and you know even if you believe with
what critical race the teaches you know
I I think it's we can see that it's
divisive and and that it's going to
cause problems and that I really don't
think we're gonna get everybody on the
same page with this and I think we
should try a different
approach you very
much oh you're
welcome I'm all set I'm all done thank
you thank you for your testimony you're
welcome thank you for having me and
Marie
Banfield
uh good afternoon thank you for taking
my testimony today honorable members of
the executive department departments and
administration my name is Amry Banfield
and I'm an advocate in New Hampshire for
academic excellence and education and
parental rights I've been advocating for
this for the last 15
years I worked recently with parents
from Hampton and the NAACP on bullying
case that involved an African-American
girl I'm well aware of the many issues
that parents are dealing with right now
but like the previous speaker I'm
receiving more and more calls from
parents and teachers on this critical
race Theory many teachers are also
concerned about what they would be
subjected to in professional development
unfortunately many of them feel that
they cannot speak publicly because what
they believe would unfairly reflect upon
them if they do not support it in the
school this would impact young children
who do not have the ability to make
these decisions for themselves Hollis
Brookline is one example but there are
others so yes this is starting to pick
up in New Hampshire in addition one
parent of un UNH student sent me a link
to critical r.org where UNH lists and it
says the University of New Hampshire
issued a statement which laid out its
black lives matter action plan the
university in the plan committed to
embedding this study of racism in to the
undergraduate curriculum however no
specific changes or steps were outlined
to accomplish this an updated an update
on curriculum changes is expected it is
unclear whether this change will include
the addition of critical race Theory
into its curriculum so UNH is in the
processing process of examining that
some speakers today have indicated that
their personal experiences may not be
introduced when it comes to diversity
training but I do not see this in the
bill the bill um I do not see how it
would prohibit thoughtful discussion on
Prejudice and racism which we I think
everyone believes that this this is an
important subject we all need to talk
about this and we all need to address it
but what parents do not want is a biased
Dogma that indoctrinates this children
and CRT is what I would consider based
on my own observation in my research a
dogma and I don't think anybody has
brought this up
we do currently limit subversive
doctrines that is already in current law
191 col1 advocacy of sub subversive
doctrines are prohibited no teacher
shall Advocate communism as a political
Doctrine or any other Doctrine which
includes the overthrow by force of the
government of the United States or of
this state in any public or state
approved school or in any state
institution RSA 189 col 26 B books
excluded no book shall be introduced
into the public schools calculated in
favor of any particular religious sect
or political party so addressing
subversive doctrines and biases are
already part of new the New Hampshire
law to a certain degree I see HB 544
expanding on that but I don't see the
the the fear that has been um
communicated in this hearing Shing it
does allow for the important discussions
on racism and sexism to continue I do
think that this is going to become a
bigger issue and I do think parents want
good quality instruction in their public
schools because this does not prohibit
quality instruction on diversity
inclusion or the views of even Martin
Luther King Jr I would support HB 544
you've been given examples today from
parents in New Hampshire there's enough
evidence that warrants this kind of
that supports equality for all so I
thank you for your time and I thank you
for taking my testimony and I do
apologize I do not have time to take
questions so um I will have to to leave
the the hearing thank you very much for
your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
hand
[Music]
Cen hi can you hear me problem conned
when I was promoted to panelist um good
afternoon members of the committee thank
you so much for letting me speak today
I'm sorry I didn't sign up I wasn't
planning on testifying today um but I um
I come here representing myself I am a
member of the group granted State
progress and a lot of the work we do is
tracking bills like these that um impose
strict limits on free speech um in the
process of live tweeting this Committee
hearing other Witnesses sent hordes of
white supremacist trolls against me and
I know that there's going to be a point
of order called about speaking about
other Witnesses so I'm going to say I'm
not going to bring that up any further
this is just to illustrate the fact that
this anti-racism training is critical to
keeping our neighbors safe here in New
Hampshire I have been attacked by over
300 different people today sending me
death threats calling me a Jewish hag um
and telling me that my speaking out
about anti-racism and speaking out about
white supremacy um is a good reason why
I should be censured um so for those who
are saying that critical race Theory and
anti-racism training are divisive
ignoring white supremacy is divisive it
leaves our neighbors vulnerable we elect
you to do everything in your power to
protect the most vulnerable people of
this state and ensure that we all have
access to high quality of life liberty
and the pursuit of happiness and
instituting this law would actively
prevent our neighbors prevent the most
vulnerable in our community from being
safe and being protected in institutions
of Higher Learning and other
state-funded public entities so I
encourage you to itl this bill think of
your neighbors who are still being
threatened every single day by White
supremacists and the fact that it is
incumbent upon all of us not just to not
be racist but to be actively seeking and
working towards a better world in which
we have fully eradicated racism thank
you so much for your time and I hope
that you'll look deep into your hearts
and find it within yourselves to itl
this bill I'm happy to take questions
thank you Miss Ken
a question representative scitec has a
question what's your name my name is
Leia Cohen I'm a resident of Molton Boro
let spell it please l e a um it is
spelled like Leah but my parents chose
to name me with the Hebrew pronunciation
thank
mlan
hello thank you madam
chair I would just like to start out on
addressing an earlier comment on the
denial of systemic racism in New
Hampshire I think that comment was
referring to on June 9th 2020 where
Governor Shu stated said comment that it
does not
exist as for the personal experience of
my life in New
Hampshire I had switch School District
from brid school at the age of six on
Martin Luther King day because on a bus
drive a student had a book that he came
from the library and I was talking about
home to my parents and had to
bring that up can't hear you very well
could you speak more clearly we're
having a lot of trouble
understanding is this better Madam chair
yes all right I'll restart that last
part at the age of six I had to leave
rich water Hein school because on Martin
Luther King day I was on a bus ride to
my grandmother's and a student had a
book talking about winching and
wanted AG go pretty much had to switch
schools because I went to my parents ask
them what that is after years of trying
to be hidden from racism I experienced
it through much of my school in my
freshman year I remember my guidance
counselor speaking about my Academia
telling my mother that it must be hard
to be a single mother racing a black
child um I
over the summer since starting
protesting have received significant
death threats one of them went viral in
many conservative social media Post in
over the news in PL New
Hampshire um I think that if we are
going to have a productive conversation
regarding race that we have to lean into
it we have to allow the proper discourse
and in line B when it says inherently
that these things are not there I think
that many of the testimonies today and
much of the media coverage from
activists all over the state telling
their
stories that is very very evident that
it exists regardless of
disposition that is my end of my um
testimony t r y s t n m c c l a i n
y Natalie Coro if that's how to
pronounce your name it's Cavo like um
yeah the Spanish pronunciation for
cheese queso so K Natalie
K thank you um thank you um committee
members and um the chair I wasn't
prepared to speak but I did catch um
come into this meeting a little late
um I a couple of things that I I've been
noticed that I that I've that I've heard
was one side feeling completely
oppressed and another side feeling
scared that they weren't going to be um
taken seriously or that their rights
were infringed on but I can't help but
notice the people that are feeling
scared scared for their lives scared for
their
children we just we just um listened to
three days of hearings on
hb20 um and in in those hearings people
were saying that their children who are
LGBT um black um specific ific Islander
um transgendered would not be accepted
to go into a Catholic
institution um because they'd be
discriminated um why are we not
teaching anti- discrimination in public
schools so these children do not have to
seek School elsewhere to seek shelter
elsewhere um I'm in strong opposition to
this bill um thank you very much for
taking my comments I apologize I am not
more prepared my emotions are a little
high after hearing all these extremely
racist comments thank you and I will
take questions if You' like thank you
for your
testimony
hi there thank you for um letting me
speak today I wasn't sure I was going to
be able to make it to this uh hearing I
am uh a registered lobbyist in the state
of New Hampshire I work for a nonprofit
called rights and
democracy and um but i' I'd really like
to just uh take a second to share with
all of you uh some of my experience
before uh I became
employed uh by this nonprofit in the
state of New Hampshire uh for five years
before that I served as in my community
as a substitute
teacher and on numerous occasions uh I
was confronted with situations where
children were uh bullying each other
because of their race or where they came
from
from I often struggled with how to deal
with this in the classroom because there
was no program for me to follow and I
often felt that I might not be supported
by my Administration or even fellow
teachers because there was a lack of
guidelines I oppose
544 immensely it is not the direction we
should be going we should be walking
into our fear of having these
conversations with each other and uh
that will that will actually get us
through this critical race Theory I have
read a ton about and um I would I would
encourage the committee and all of the
people here today to do more research
and not from a biased position on what
critical race theory is and it is not it
is not a political ideology in fact I
disagree PE with people who believe in
critical race Theory all the time there
is a vast and immense amount of folks uh
with different opinions but they do
agree that we have a really a problem
with race in this country that really
needs to be dealt with head-on so I
encourage us uh all to work on this
together and to oppose this bill and uh
it really doesn't have any place in the
state of New Hampshire thank so much for
taking the time to listen to my thoughts
and thank you for all that you
do thank you for your
testimony is there anyone else who
wishes to testify there's
just wasn't that
she wasn't that he St that was me I just
spoke oh
sorry you're all set I think that may be
it
snowing oh yeah so that SN KN it
not all right if there's nobody else who
wishes to testify on House Bill 544 I'm
going to close public
hearing we are recessed for the day we
are going to resume on Monday morning at
o'